this is Jocko podcast number 185 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening echo good evening
you get one shot and that's it and in
the end you're going into the ground
regardless of what you believe the
afterlife consists of or what it doesn't
consists of as far as what you get to
hold on to once you leave here is
nothing and I implore people all the
time to make it count because this is it
this is the finals there are no redos
you can't hit the rewind button and even
worse you can't even hit the pause
button there's no way you can stop the
clock from ticking no possible way the
countdown is on and the days are finite
you only get so many then then it's over
so until them make them count make all
of them count and on the podcast today I
have a guest
a fellow frog man whom to the best of my
knowledge is doing his best to make his
days count his name is Mitch a gr
and we just met each other but like I
said he's a frogman he likes jiu-jitsu
he likes to get after it so my guess is
we should have some things to talk about
so Mitch walked with a podcast thanks
for having me
good good to meet you yeah good to meet
you fifteen minutes ago yeah
picked you up at the airport I think we
linked up some way on social media
correct and you were in the AL doing
some training and so here you are cool
where'd you grow up I grew up in
Virginia Beach and then was there till
about 11:00 then moved to Maryland and
live of my dad was there till about 16
and so wait grow up in Virginia Beach
parents in the military yep my mom and
dad were both in the Navy both in the
nav that's right yeah and my mom was an
OS and my dad was a combat camera man
with deaf group okay right off and and
so then used were there until you said
you were 11 yeah I was in Virginia Beach
tell us 11 they were divorced and my dad
had gotten out of the Navy and was
living up in Maryland working at the
Aberdeen Proving Ground okay doing
high-speed photography there and uh you
know filming tank rounds and all kinds
of cool explosives and stuff like that
and you had like a wicked cool job he
had before it was cool wicked cool yeah
and so I went up there and lived with
him for a while and then around 16 moved
up to Ohio my mom had moved up to Ohio
my stepdad was also in the Navy and he
had gotten out and they started a
business up in Ohio and I went and lived
with her up there and finished out high
school in Ohio
no 10th or 10th 11th 12th grade and then
joined the Navy from there what what was
high school like what sports were you
play I was playing football basketball
lacrosse and yeah was it we're gonna do
it we're good athlete I was a good
athlete and I was also
to some sports that weren't at our
school I was on a arm wrestling team
around a dodgeball team like a traveling
dodgeball team a traveling dodgeball
team it was it was by far my favorite
like how how many games would you play
in dodgeball in a day no in like a
season what's this the dodgeball season
well you know there's practice obviously
and if you take it serious like we did
we practice like three times a week and
then we would travel on the weekends for
tournaments what balls do you use we
some some leagues are different but
mainly it's those kick balls so like the
red rubber ones yeah how many people are
on the team each side um there was it
was like six or seven people per team or
and then we had like a couple
substitutes you know in case there was
injuries injuries just like any other
sport man we had your first string
starters and then you but you didn't
wrestle I did not wrestle
I didn't resurrect that well I did into
run cross-country I didn't swim I didn't
do anything in high school that would be
useful in my ongoing adventures well
football basketball I mean you're
becoming an athlete yeah like just in
general I would well I would say that
competition mindset you know that and
just yeah being an athlete overall that
was always something that was just in
grayned in me you know my both my mom
and dad and they were really competitive
like always had us in sports growing up
my brother and I and yeah I always loved
the competition side of things you know
and I actually like hate working out
still to this day like I just I don't
really enjoy it but if there's some sort
of competition involved in it or
competitiveness that's that's what I
really like shark so you get done with
high school
your and you what makes you join the
Navy honestly I was I was just bored I
was living in Ohio and it sucked there
and there was just nothing there that I
wanted how long after you graduated high
school did you join the Navy
a couple months did you did you go in
the dive fair program to be in the teams
or did you just want to be in just in
the Navy now I originally um I mean it
it it wasn't planned out at all I was I
was working three different jobs I was a
roofer which I really really loved that
was that was a great job and I worked at
my my parents like they owned a deli
slash convenience store kind of thing I
worked there and I was a lifeguard at
kalahari and I and I was a surf
instructor he said kalahari I already
know that's it's an it's the world's
largest indoor water park okay and they
have waves there yeah I have a flow
rider like a couple flow rider machines
oh the thing that she wanted us the
plastic yeah you type there yet what
creates an artificial wave so I would uh
I was on the competition team and I
would like give people lessons on how to
ride that thing so between that and
dodgeball every kind of dial did yeah
for some action that's right that's a
good setup so you recommend if someone
wants to get the career of Special
Operations they focus on dodgeball and
arm wrestling and say awesome how much a
formula for success formula for success
and so you're you're you're doing these
jobs and you're you're not having a good
time with you yeah I ever I was you know
not a very good studious student in high
school you know high school was more of
like a socialization for me like I
really enjoyed going there socialized I
really enjoyed
you know making friends and I liked
sports and and I was always I always
loved working and making money you know
like school is just kind of in the way
I'd kind of you know at the time I just
had zero interest in any sort of
classwork whatsoever and I don't even
understand how I somehow I had graduated
and then you know I was like yeah I'm
definitely gonna do something in life I
don't know what I'm assuming it'll be
good though you know I just don't know
what it is and and my teachers were kind
of in that same mindset they're you know
half of them were just like man they're
you're hopeless like there's you're just
gonna work at Burger King whatever and
then the other half were just like yeah
you're gonna do something great it's
definitely not going to be in school you
know who knows what it is and I was just
kind of in that you know glass half-full
I was thinking the same thing
and I didn't know what it was honestly
like I said I was roofing and I really
loved roofing but yeah you know I was
making minimal money and I knew that
that wasn't going to be it so I was in
the area I knew that nothing around the
area interested me you know there was
nothing that I wanted to pursue around
there I was young I was 18 you know my
mom and dad were both in my stepdad
where we're all in the Navy at at points
in their life and you know had talked
about the benefits of the military my
dad was always trying to get me to go in
the military and I just wasn't
interested at all and yeah that was
never really even a consideration until
quite literally like I was just bored
and the recruiter happened to walk in
catch me and I was like hey you want to
join the Navy and I was like sure why
not
and
and I was at first I was going to do
mastered arms like I was like uh you
know I've always I've always had like a
kind of respect for police my
grandfather's a police officer my
uncle's still a police officer and that
was something that I felt like you know
was a courageous job and a helpful
useful one or whatever you know and I
figured that I could I've always been
real protective as well so like I
figured that job would kind of maybe be
fitting for me so he he had asked me you
know hey yeah you want to join the Navy
and I was like okay and then I thought
oh I'll go that route and he was like
well you look like you're in good shape
do you want to you want to be a seal I
was like there's a sneaky guys you know
the the only thing I knew about seals
was from that commercial where the where
the they're on the beach or it's a scene
and it's on the beach and the clouds
roll over the moon and then they pass to
supremacy or whatever and so that's all
I knew about Navy SEALs and I was like
ah this guy's what beer is this this was
2007 Jay so you're watching the wars are
going on all through high school you're
seeing all that stuff take place mm-hmm
9/11 happened when I was in seventh
grade there you were probably boots on
ground or something there well I mean I
was I was yeah I had been in for like 11
years at that point so I joined in 90 so
I was born in 89 yeah yeah
so I'm a little bit older than you are
apparently yeah did you not
did you realize like so this was your
first kind of connection cuz for me when
I was growing up like every time some
kind of war event happened I was all
bummed out that I wasn't there because I
was too young
and that's just the way I was I was
always thinking about that I was always
into the military but you were kind of
like not
I was the total opposite like I wanted
nothing to do with with the military I
wanted nothing to do with like I'd never
even thought about it my dad was just
you know he was in and he was a combat
cameraman with deaf groups so obviously
he was you know really involved with
with it and any time he would try and
talk to me if I'm just like I'm I'm not
interested I'm not gonna join the
fucking military but you know what what
flip the switch just mega boredom yeah
just I just you know I was like well
worst case scenario I know I'm in for in
the Navy for four years I'll go see the
world a little bit I'll you know gain
some life experience and worst case I
get out and I'm fucking 22 yeah like who
cares I'm not going to college I know
that you know high school was I barely
made it through that and just not
because I'm stupid just because I just
man wasn't your scene oh my god I'd
rather do hell week ten times in a row
than write an essay you know so you get
in the Navy and do you prepare at all
like before I had never run like further
than a mile and like I all my sprint all
my sports stuff was all sprinting I mean
those dodge balls are only you know
dodge ball courts were small yeah
they're cold they're they're short so
it's just I was always a really fast
sprinter and uh that was kind of all I
really cared about I I didn't even I was
also I also like now looking back how
stupid I was and just how dumb you are
at 18 like you think you really like
Nora when you're 18 you really like
you're like man you know you look back
at when you're 10 they're like I know so
much yeah I just compared to my
seven-year-old self compared to my
eight-year-old self like I didn't even
know what I was doing now I'm a I'm a
man you know I know what what life's
about but at that point obviously now
I'm thirty looking back at that I'm just
like man you're so dumb but I really was
and just really inexperienced with life
I never like I said run
really further than a mile I didn't even
understand like that people did that I
had heard about like marathons and stuff
but I remember when you know and when I
had heard that I had to run like a mile
and a half for the PST I was like what
in the fuck like why what and then and
then like I told my dad that I signed up
for the the SEAL Teams and I was like
hey I'm gonna be a seal and he's just
like you have no idea what you just
signed up for I didn't even know I had
to go to buds and then so he was like
yeah what's wrong and he he bought me
the the two three four documentary and
we sat down and watched that and I
remember like just watching the four
mile timed run and I was just thinking
like is that even possible
like do people really do that and I was
just thinking like Jesus Christ like
this is I'm gonna have to do all this
shit oh my god I better start running I
better start training so did you start
running and trading yeah I mean I went
out and you know actually back up before
I even saw that the first the first
introduction I had two buds was I or
Navy SEALs in general once I signed the
like I signed up and I was like all
right I'm gonna be a Navy SEAL I better
do some research so I went out and got
Navy SEALs with Charlie Sheen and I
watched that and that was my very first
introduction to what Navy SEALs were and
I was just like man looks pretty intense
pretty cool though and you know in the
scene the scene in that movie they say
it's buds but it's obviously not because
it's like in the woods and they're like
there's like grenades going off and
they're like they're like army crawling
under barbed wire and and he's like this
is buds you know like it was just like
this crazy scene or whatever
and I was just thinking like damn I got
to go through all that all right better
so I went out and bought some fucking
camo pants I bought some boots like just
leather boots and there and I went for a
run down my street and I remember it was
like a mile all right did I was like I
have to run a mile in half so I'm gonna
see how this goes and I and I went and
got those pants and got suited up and I
was just thinking like oh man this is
gonna be hard but and then and then my
dad got the the 2 3 4 documentary and
then I was just like oh ok I really just
have no fucking idea what I just signed
up for and I was just thinking like damn
that looks really hard but I already
told everyone that I was going to do
this and I was just kind of that you
know that's one good thing about being
18 and you're just young and dumb and
stubborn and you know luckily I used the
the good of that to get through I guess
so you get in the I was gonna say you
know mice mice my dive motivator was
Mike nos you know yes I know who it is I
don't know him personally but well he's
he's a whole Vietnam frogman plank owner
at at Dam Neck and he he came in and
he's a tall guy and he walks with like
kind of a big limp because he had like a
hip replacement he still swims like a
fish and he actually taught me how to do
the sidestroke the day before my PST so
it was like pretty steep learning curve
so it's that is I always tell people not
to make decisions when they're super
emotional and so I'm gonna start adding
don't make decisions when you're super
just bored yeah yeah you might end up at
buds so you show up there you show up
the buds and you must have you know
obviously you made it through was
already what was your worst off for you
and buds running running was definitely
I mean obviously that's like what you do
the most of
and man it was just I went from no
running ever to running my ass off just
everywhere and and those timed runs man
I was just fucking having a lot of
conversations with Jesus those runs and
just you know giving it everything I
fucking had just to make the cutoff on
those on those runs and then and then I
eventually I became like a pretty good
runner from doing it and but yeah I was
I was for sure captain of the goon squad
and but luckily all those fucking
dodgeball Sprint's were paying off in
the goon squad so it was it was nice in
the goon squad I felt comfortable did
you get rolled for anything yeah I got
rolled for some I had real bad shin
splints from for living from the lack of
running previous and but other you know
got rolled dealt with that and like I
said I picked up like from running so
much I just got good at it and I was
like young so adapted well I guess yeah
it pays to be young and buds in my
opinion yeah I'm a physical perspective
physically F for sure with like dealing
with overuse injuries and I mean because
you're definitely gonna just they're
obviously just gonna fucking ream your
ass and then you have to get up and go
yeah I was talking to one of the medical
guys there who came from like a sports
environment like the I think the NFL was
easy and I think was the NFL and do you
remember the I think it's patella
femoral syndrome did you ever know
anyone that got that there anyways
there's a bunch of people that get this
this this patella femoral syndrome you
know there and he said yeah at Budds I
would see 10 cases a week of patella
femoral syndrome it's where your patella
like rubs against your your femur or
something and he said in the NFL you'd
see like one of these every year maybe
one a year and so these guys that would
come to buds for
from a physical what was an athletic
trainer perspective would learn so much
because they're just getting these mat
these of bodies are just going through
abuse like no other bodies and so they
see all those all these common injuries
that you get your knees your your
shoulders your back like that's what you
go to Budds as an athletic trainer you
learn and as a doctor you learn so much
about how to deal with these things
because you see ten times more than you
would or more than you would anywhere
else yeah I believe that
but I've also talked people who say like
I was young too going through buds how
old were you 18 and so you get the you
get the you get the mind of hey I just
do whatever they tell me to do you know
but there's some people that say have
told me they didn't think they were
mature enough at 18 or 19 to go through
buds um I for sure was not I don't say I
wasn't mature enough to go through
because obviously I did and I made it
through however you say like what or ask
like what my biggest struggle at Budds
was was definitely my maturity I mean
physically like physically it was
running like just I was never a
long-distance runner obviously sprinting
I was fast as fuck sprinting and I was
really strong on the log and like the
boats the boats on heads was extremely
surprising to me I like I remember
seeing it on the videos and thinking
like okay that's kind of weird like why
are they running around boats on their
heads like and then I didn't think it
was gonna be painful because they're
they're like inflatable the rubber boats
or whatever and then when they put that
thing on your head I was just like Jesus
Christ this thing is smashing my fucking
neck did the instructors jump around in
the boats when you went through yeah
stop doing it at some point they would
like some of the little guys would like
jump and hang on the handles and and
shit like that when when you're running
but yeah you definitely knew when they
were on the boats because they got a lot
heavier but um what they would do when I
went through and they stopped doing this
which is a good thing they would they
would be like the boats who be lined up
and we
Hammond head carry and the instructors
would be in like boat one and rather
than they would just jumped into boat
two and then jump into boat three and I
remember hearing when they would did
that to me a couple of the times that
they did it to me I heard like this
deep kind of inside my neck and I
remember thinking this is probably not
good and they stopped doing it
thankfully because that's not healthy
so you actually used to be like six to I
don't know if I got shorter but I
definitely took some took some damage
took some damage for sure yeah that was
that the boats on heads was probably the
most surprising thing to me of how like
I just wasn't expecting it to be that
bad and but like the log PT you know I
was always really enjoyed the log PT I
think probably because from roofing you
know I was always carrying those 80
pound bundles of shingles up the ladder
and then like I was the young guy on the
crew so I was a shingle bitch over the
years and you know everyone everyone on
my crew is in their forties so they you
know I was the 15 year old when I came
on the crew and just a young strong kid
they they took full advantage of it and
just wherever they needed shingles on
the roof that's where I called them up
and so I was used to carrying you know
that the heavy load and stuff and like I
said I feel strong I felt really good on
that stuff and mentally I was like I
just was super competitive and that's
what really got me through buds was was
just that sheer competitiveness where
did the maturity level where could that
have tripped you up were you like doing
dumb stuff on the weekends where you
know not really um because I mean I
wasn't even old enough to go drink or
anything like that so it was more just
kind of not understanding well one like
I was different I was different than
most people there because like you said
you wanted to be in the military your
whole life and like you wanted to be a
seal I'm assuming
did you yeah I mean as soon as I kind of
figured out what the single themes were
yeah yeah so like like that and just how
you are
you're very disciplined you're very you
know you're very militant I would say
and I would have to concur yeah I was
like more of like a wild like free
spirit kind of you know kid growing up
and and I was not militant at all and so
and I also like getting through boot
camp was difficult for me because of
that as well you know just like I'm like
why my my question was like why do we
have to fold or make cars or whatever
we're literally spent all day undoing
our bed and and remaking it I was like I
what the fuck this is the point of this
like it's such a waste of time
and you know obviously it's all for a
reason and designed but I just I
couldn't wrap my head around it so that
just lack of military bearing and lack
of maturity and understanding like why
things are the way they are and you know
the whole military structure just you
just do it and you don't question stuff
like that you know that was probably my
biggest hang-up you know just I was
different than everyone I was young I
was I don't know I I didn't want to be a
seal my whole life you know some of
these people like this is like their
dream and they've been training for it
for whatever and I'm just kind of here
showing up and and guys are quitting and
and I'm not and you know and and like
physically I was doing like a lot better
than some guys who like I said it was
kind of just like I am just here
whatever doing this and other guys it's
like this is everything to me and you
know so it's like I check so you get
done with buds and you show up and
where'd you go team ten team ten yeah
right on and then well how was that
checking in to team ten it was it was
cool but by that point you know I'd kind
of like
obviously I was like oh right I'm a seal
now and and I had been in the in the
pipeline for a while and kind of getting
in the flow of things and the military
and and stuff like that but yeah I was
super excited to check in to team ten
and I originally I was going to go to
team five and then my I told my family
you know that I've got orders to five
and and they were all kind of bummed out
because they wanted they're all in the
East Coast and they were like ah man you
know we were hoping you'd come with East
Coast and I was like okay I'll go to
these coasts and I thought it was like
kind of cool too because it felt like
like a new like a new chapter because
like you know the SEAL team one three
and five or seven or right by the buds
compound so it was like you know I'd
been there and been in this scene for
the last two years or whatever it was
and it was it was cool felt cool to like
go across the country and like check in
to a team and you know I just felt like
like this is it this is a real deal so
that was super cool I felt felt good
my troop was awesome and what was your
what was your job and your first Platoon
I was a heavy gunner for sure a dub a
knuckle draggers yeah yeah yeah that's a
classic new guy strong new guy guess
what yeah I'm a pig you're a big strong
new guy
got something for you and I loved it
yeah I I am I I embraced it I didn't
think it was like a bad thing
you know I think what year is this now
2009 okay so you yeah you went straight
to the to the mark 48 no and the 64 you
mm-hmm
that's that's that's nice yeah we shot
60s and stuff but no like what like a
fam 60s or something yeah and there were
60s on like Humvees and stuff like that
and going through vehicle stuff so there
was still a little bit of transition
taking place so you're a paid gunner
your first Platoon
how was your first work up it was
awesome
it's definitely a good time got what
surprised you about like going through
workup being in a seal puts here what
what was different than what you thought
it was what was different from how it
was for Charlie Sheen you know it was it
was a lot like the movie it was it was
it was great man I I I thought it was a
lot of fun we got to travel travel the
travel the country that was a cool thing
too about the East Coast the training
sites were kind of all over all over
versus the west coast it was kind of
like the same song and dance like niland
and and what's the other one
you know in the training the trainings
like all the same sites and so going to
the East Coast I got to see a bunch of
new places and and that was cool to me
just kind of seeing the world and the
the Brotherhood of like being in the
troops and and stuff and you're you're
rolling around as a team I thought that
that was really cool was there anything
that was more challenging like you know
some new guys they have a hard time in
their first platoon with whatever with
land warfare they have a hard time with
CQC they'll have a hard time with some
you know whatever sometimes it's like
not easy sometimes you know you get a
guy that can't dive very well or
whatever was anything that wasn't a
skillset that was hard for you or did
you pretty much which is I would say
most guys coming out of buds and sqt
like most of them are fine like most of
them yet get they can they pick things
up pretty quick you know they made it
through all that crap they made it
through sqt where you're getting
screened right again so most the time
but still you'd still get guys showing
up a platoon that you know they wouldn't
be comfortable with this or they
wouldn't be great at that was there
anything that was tough for you I would
say like everything was was tough I I
wasn't I wasn't a master at anything
other than my Pig you know and
so everything was was was somewhat
challenging for me but I also didn't
really struggle with anything to too
much other than like my maturity like
that you know I was I checked into a
SEAL team before I could even go into a
bar you know and I didn't go to college
or anything like that so I was I was a
20 year old at a SEAL team yeah you know
so yes I had been through a lot as far
as like buds and sqt and you know that
kind of forces you to grow up to an
extent but seals like to party too and
and I kind of that was probably my
biggest challenge was just my maturity
and just kind of learning when to to
lock on and and you know when it was
time to like chill out did you ever get
caught that you ever get in trouble do
you ever get arrested I did get arrested
and not in my new guy platoon I got
arrested in my and when I was in my
second platoon I got into a bar fight
this these guys it was actually three
three dudes had just started mouthing
off to one of my platoon members wife it
was him and I and my girlfriend at the
time and his girlfriend at the time now
her wife and we were coming out of the
bar and they just had a couple drinks
and they had come over and said some
disrespectful shit to them and you know
I just was feeling froggy a little bit
and didn't let it slide and ended up
whooping their ass and beat up three
people outside of a bar and got arrested
mm-hmm but but your first Platoon you
you managed to keep your nose clean or
at least as far as you know the actual
log the actual law enforcement goes yeah
not tremble and then where was that so
you did your work up where did you guys
go on deployment to your first
deployment
Afghanistan
and when you were going to Afghanistan
were you going did you go as a whole
troop to Afghanistan yep yeah all three
of our platoons went yeah it was it was
kind of an interesting thing because it
was in 2011 and I don't know if you you
said you got out in 2010 I did yeah well
yeah there was I'm sure you heard about
they they wanted us to somehow get on
the army schedule and so it was us and
Team seven mm-hmm and we ended up
basically doing two deployments back to
back and got synced up with the army or
something like that and I don't know I
don't know all the all the you know
mumbo jumbo that actually took place but
or why we did it but they told us kind
of right before it was like two months
before we left they're like hey just
kidding you guys are gonna go to
Afghanistan and we're gonna need you
stay there for basically a year or the
goat shit okay so we went there and it
was it was an interesting deployment for
sure because my platoon
we were the furthest outpost from any
major base in Afghanistan and you know
were basically roughing it the whole
time we were out there did you guys take
over at outpost somewhere or did you
guys establish one we took one over that
had just been established like literally
a couple months ago you know so there
was there was nothing there we were
sleeping in tents still no running water
no no nothing like that and then I think
around month seven or eight of our
deployment we packed up and went 15
miles north and set up a new site so it
was literally just fucking roughing it
the whole
time you know airdrop in our food in and
and no running water the whole time and
what what type of ops were you doing
we were we were doing all kinds of stuff
and I was lucky enough to kind of we got
to they shifted our guys around too so
like we got to all that kind of
experience different things because we
all had a different kind of mission set
and different we were on all three of
our platoons were in different areas of
Afghanistan so I got to kind of do a lot
of everything so were you guys going out
on patrol from your from your Forward
Operating Base was that yeah and yeah
pretty much daily and you were
interacting with a local populace type
thing yep you know try to establish
relationships yeah we did that for a
little while that was a really dumb that
you because you didn't feel like you
made any progress didn't make any
connections yeah I mean in in my opinion
I just thought it was like kind of a
waste of time and I just I just felt
like we could have been doing a lot more
stuff or better stuff with our time and
and training and all that and it was
just like a super dangerous area to be
in you know it was in Helmand and is it
we basically just lived in a fucking
minefield you know and it was just
IEDs everywhere just as a constant
threat so you know and we were going on
these long patrols every day and and all
these all these ops we were doing and
hitting these villages that were just
riddled with IEDs everywhere and you
know getting contacted you know on
you're basically just stick out like a
sore thumb there you know so I mean you
know how Versys I didn't feel real
comfortable with that like and it sucked
being in a minefield like just every
step just please don't blow please don't
blow up please don't blow up please
don't
you know for a year yeah did you guys
did you guys hit any IEDs yeah yeah we
encountered a couple IEDs and so shitty
yeah
and that the enemy did you have a feel
for who was bad and who was good when
you'd go out no definitely not there was
I mean cuz like literally there was
there was a times where you know we'd be
in the village fucking shaking hands
with people and then you know on the way
out get contacted getting a firefight
and then fucking go back and look and oh
it's the same guys that we were just
shaking hands with that are fucking dead
you know and so it was it was hard to it
was really weird to like get rep ramped
up and everything as he's like getting
this mindset of this warrior mindset you
know that you're going to war and you're
going to this fucking land where
everyone everyone is you know your enemy
and blah blah blah
and then it's like oh just kidding let's
let's try to help some of these people
or whatever and and the you know the
good and use like okay yeah I want to I
want to help people and and stuff like
that and and do what I can to help these
people out and and if they're getting
like bullied essentially by the by the
Taliban or whatever like that's not cool
but I just felt like it was it was
really weird to to be there and go there
with that mindset and then have to
fucking like trying to help people and
then when you try to help people they
don't want your help and you know and
they fucking shoot at you and and shit
like that so it's like and then you're
expected to like go out and try and help
these people again and it's I don't know
it was just like a weird it's a weird
dynamic
and would you go when you said you would
move positions where you going from like
would you like switch platoons and go to
a different Operating Base yeah and then
you'd spend some time there with them
and and then do operations with them and
then after a little while go to a
different one as well yeah yeah we
rotated our guy all of our guys just to
so we can all get you know experience
doing other things like working with the
commandos or you know training the fit
trainin FID or doing the VSO stuff and
yeah it was cool I enjoyed that just
because it broke up the monotony of
everyday you know going on patrols doing
the same things seeing the same places
or whatever and dealing with the same
threats
it just it keeps you kind of from
getting complacent I felt like so
obviously for the 11 month or yeah so I
was definitely happy to move and and do
new things and work and like and it was
cool too because on the base that we
were at in Afghanistan it was literally
like a hundred yards by a hundred yards
that was your that was like our camp it
was like being in prison you know but
worse like because we're getting shot at
too and like if you when you go outside
go get your fucking food that they
airdrop in you know you're worried about
stepping on IDs like we found IEDs
literally right outside of our compound
you know so it was a constant threat
always and and like I said like going to
get our air dry it was just a lot of
work to because not only it was like we
were seal bees you know we had to like
build our we had to like build our camp
and also like all the stuff that came
with that like going and getting our
supplies that would airdrop in and and
being out there you know you only get
ring routes and and stuff you only get
air drops every once in a while and so
when when shit would come in it was like
all hands
go work on this and then also you got to
prep your shit and get ready for the OP
tonight or tomorrow or whatever and and
I remember just I have a video of one of
our big air drops coming in and you just
see like three or four pallets just burn
in just explode and you know it's like
always it like all the water-bottle
pallets are fine but it's that one with
like the goodies you know it's like oh
man you know that's the one that burned
in and it just fucking hits the ground
explodes and you see like all the rip
it's or something you know it's
something that people were looking
forward to just explode and you're just
like fuck I don't know I just accepted
that this is my life so sure whatever I
wasn't I wasn't thinking about the time
too much and then um I just you get into
a rhythm you know and I got to we got to
go home for R&R that was cool took a
little break but it was like bittersweet
you know go home for fucking two weeks
and like I've just been playing in this
minefield where everyone's trying to
kill me for the last six months and come
home for two weeks and like to normalcy
and you're just like you know literally
just fly straight from there no
decompression or anything and then now
you're back in normal society with your
family and and by the way you're leaving
in 11 days to go back yeah and then
don't get comfortable because we're
going right back over there so that was
like kind of like it was bittersweet and
got back over there but that was cool
too because it was like re I'm fuckin
halfway through like it's downhill now
you know so that kind of definitely
fired me up to finish out but then
towards the end we were there for all
four seasons so we saw literally all
four seasons this is interesting and by
the end of it
by the end of it I remember when the
ring route came to pick me up to go out
I remember flying away from from the
base that we were at and just thinking
like oh my
kind of sad like like almost like when
you move away from somewhere and like
I've moved my whole life I've moved
around a lot so I was like damn like
this has been my home for the last year
you know I'm kind of bummed to to leave
but fuck this place I can't wait to go
home yeah I got I got kind of lucky
because I had been in the Navy for a
while when when I deployed to Iraq and
especially my second deployment to Iraq
where I was in Ramadi and and like I I
you know sometimes people will say oh I
look back and I I wish I would have
appreciated it more you know people say
that about certain parts of their life I
don't have that at all like i 100%
appreciated every single day I was there
I was like this is this is the the best
part of my whole life is right is what's
happening today right now you know so I
got kind of lucky in the fact that you
know even talking to the guys that were
new guys on that deployment to her body
they they just kind of they were like
from then honey maybe say a damn you
know I thought that's what every
deployment was gonna be like it was and
it was they just didn't have that same
perspective of hey man this is like this
target-rich environment where we're
getting to do what everyone's dreamed of
doing their whole life and they're gonna
do it all the time that doesn't happen
you know it doesn't happen like that
usually you know and it's hard and so I
was pretty lucky in the fact that I I
was I could appreciate it
yeah I know as far as the work went like
I was as far as like like being a seal
and working there like that that was
awesome you know and I was you know one
of the biggest like I say concerns I had
or not or even that concern was just
like a question to myself was you know
what would how am I actually going to
react in combat you know what I mean
because everyone everyone likes to think
that they're ideally you know and in a
situation of shit popped off you know
I'll be the I'll be the guy who will you
know hold have my shit together and and
be that you know the rock or whatever
you know what I mean
and some people crumble you know and I
saw that as a seal like that that was
kind of my I was always a realist you
know was like I've never been shot at
I've never been in a gunfight or
whatever so I definitely you know I I
feel like I'm not a coward and I feel
like I would step up and do do what I
got to do and perform I feel like that
but I don't know it for sure you know
what I mean and so that was that was
definitely when it happened and I in it
you know and I did I I stepped up and
and felt very pleased with with how that
all went down and and all the combat and
everything that I had been involved with
like that was definitely rewarding to me
you know like as a seal and and as a man
just and as a warrior just like okay
like I felt legit you know I felt like
fulfilled in that sense so the work the
work was really good but just as far as
being in that environment like the IEDs
was really like the IEDs and the fucking
like invisible enemy was kind of
discouraging you know it was like it
felt like we just had so much risk you
know for not a whole lot of reward and
like which is different like I would say
I would I feel like an like Ramadi was
like a different just way different
environment but yeah ya know that's
that's the that's the way insurgents are
supposed to fight right you're not
supposed to see them they're just
supposed to pick away at you the death
of a thousand cuts that you know
indirect fire IEDs and snipers and they
don't want you to ever see them and and
that's what they want and just to slowly
pick away because they don't care about
human life they don't value human life
and here we are you know every time we
lose someone it's it's a tragedy
and they don't care if they lose guys or
not they don't they don't care they
don't care if the civilians get killed
don't care about any of that and so
that's why they have that's why they
have an advantage in those situations a
psychological advantages hey we we don't
care if you kill us and by the way we
know you care about your people and so
we're gonna pick away and you're
hopefully you're never going to see us
and we don't care we're gonna blow you
up and we don't care yeah that I mean
that was pretty apparent I mean because
a lot of the IEDs that went off were you
know local villagers stepping on them
triggered by Sabaa you know and then
that that just happened all that all the
damn time and and we would we would help
them you know we would we would aid the
wounded and stuff like that and they'd
like get pissed at us and we're like we
didn't plant that shit you know like get
mad at them not us yeah that's that that
insurgency thing is but yeah and like
more to do worth it was it was just
super frustrating to me like it was
super frustrating to me dealing with
like the politics involved with war and
you know I felt like we absolutely could
have done things to give us more of an
advantage but it seemed like they were
more concerned with politics and shit
like that you know as more than more
than like the safety of us and I just
felt like we could you know there's no
reason why we should be going out in the
daylight
period you know we train like why not
fight like we train and because you guys
got locked down from doing stuff at
night right right we got to do night
shit but we also did a lot of day shit
and I you know to me it was just like
why the fuck are we doing this like we
have night vision why are we going out
there and did you have Afghan forces
with you sometimes mm-hmm a lot of times
we did we we had to work a lot in Ramadi
in the daytime
then the main
we have worked well there's a couple big
reasons why we worked in the daytime in
Ramadi which as you just pointed out as
a huge tactical disadvantage compared to
being out at night where we can
literally see and the enemy can't
I mean it's but in Ramadi you know we
had to work with Iraqi soldiers who
didn't have night vision so they didn't
have flashlights they would have like
one flashlight for every four people and
we two eventually got him flashlights
and stuff but anyways it was it was a
problem because to go out at night with
them it was they were blind and so now
you're you're like at a you're at this
say the same disadvantage because you're
trying to you got people that can't see
mix with people that can't see and
they're not getting anything out of it
they're not improving their skills at
all and they're just horrible yeah and
they were they were not not good not
good and so that was one reason was to
take him out in the daytime we to get
him to operate we had to go out with him
in the daytime and the other big one was
the enemy knew that we owned the night
and so the enemy in Ramadi they didn't
come out at night they came out in the
daytime so if you wanted to kill them
you had to go out when they were when
they were moving and so that's where
we're now and you know we did both and
we did a ton at the night as well and
also you know we take advantage of the
night to get in good positions we know
when and then during the daytime they
would come out to fight and you know
they'd get it yeah we had we had art we
had we were working with the commandos
and they had night vision but like I
said they were just terrible and like
one of them almost shot me on and op we
were actually in a helicopter flying to
target and it was one of their heavy
gunners and he it was around midnight
and we were flying in a Chinook to to
the target and I was just kind of
nodding off just you know just just
trying to you know catch a little nap on
the ride to the OP and its pitch black
in the in the helo obviously and all of
a sudden it's just correct you know like
four or five rounds crack off and
the guy neck it was the guy next to me
and thank God he had his barrel down and
like literally just shot like four or
five rounds like less than six inches
from my feet and there's just holes in
the bottom of the the bird and shot the
comms out of the helo and everything and
at that point I was just like you know I
was there just kind of used to shit me
and shitty and just reached over and
took the rounds out of his gun and just
that was the safest weapon yeah just
like come over comms like yeah the
fucking commandos ad you know never ones
just like whatever but so then we
changed like all right no more commandos
rolling hot in the birds and you know on
the way to target target and so we we
had changed that so then the next one we
did we fucking got to we got to our our
target bird landed get out and do our
formation and all the sudden in its like
a total brown out you know because
Afghanistan's super dusty and everything
there and the the helo lands we're all
getting our in our formation and it's a
total Brown out and then all of a sudden
we hear fucking rounds going off crack
around because the the dudes loading
their pigs like all sudden had to run
away gun or whatever we don't know if
we're getting contacted like you can
hear it's outgoing but like why why is
there outgoing fire when we're in
filling you know are we get in contact
or what's going on and it's just these
guys are fucking stupid with their
weapons and yeah so it was always always
something fun always good so you wrap up
that deployment and come back to come
back and roll into your next ya exporter
ya come back and roll into the next
button and I always wanted to how was
that how was that coming home now you're
now you're home you did the two weeks in
the middle how was the transition when
you got home
it was it was it was rough
I was definitely dealing with some PTSD
I would say and I was I was definitely
kind of angry um I was I was angry it
was a weird weird weird emotions because
I I kind of was kind of pissed off at
like America like like not America as a
whole but like I felt like the politics
you know like I said earlier I felt like
they really cared more about or they
just didn't really give a shit about our
safety I felt like you know it's one
thing like obviously we're doing a
dangerous job but why why on earth are
we not giving ourselves every advantage
that we are capable of you know like
like the night vision and stuff like
that and and a lot of times we would
capture people who we knew we're bad you
know talking to our Intel guys and
they're like 100% like this dude is a
fucking terrorist like he's a bad dude
like everyone in his phone you know
they'd rip apart the shit and like every
one of his contacts are bad you know
like this guy's definitely an ie D maker
you know whatever and so we've got these
guys captured but then we have to turn
him in to the Afghan government which we
also know is corrupt and then all of a
sudden these dudes are out on the
streets again
in a couple months time and making IEDs
that you know me or my brothers can step
on and fucking that's a wrap and you
know Caleb Nelson was a seal that died
on our deployment from my team and
it's just kind of you know life and
death and war it just puts things in a
perspective and it really made me angry
that you know like Caleb couldn't come
home because of an IE D and like we're
letting these people go and and I just
felt like we weren't being utilized
fully and and like like it was costing
us and so I was like really angry about
that and um and then also just kind of
being in that environment for a long
time just different you know different
mentality and then coming home to
America and like people just don't
understand how good it is here and it's
like a fucking fairy tale you know and
and trying and listening to people talk
and complain about about shit here and
I'm just like you don't even have to you
don't even you just walk down that
sidewalk and didn't even give a fuck
where you stepped like you don't even
care because you're not worried about
anything you're not worried if there's
an IUD they're like you have running
water you took a shower today
you fucking I had to burn my own shit
you know um so I was just like a lot of
anger dealing with that and I was
drinking a lot like and I also felt like
I felt like seals were the only ones
that kind of understood and got it and
then also being over there in
Afghanistan I saw you know Kandahar the
main base in Kandahar was like a fucking
it was like a little town you know
there's like flag football leagues and
shopping and TGI Fridays people having
birthday parties and shit like that and
you know that's where that's where like
Tim McGraw flies in to do the concert
for the troops and shit like that you
know
like is this where we're staying eating
like kings you know and they're like
nanana you're going out there so then
you know that's where I that's where I
was and that's where where me and my
boys were you know living in the suck
livings doing some serious fuckin shitty
living you know and and and working a
job as dangerous as fuck every day and
then just seeing that kind of shit and
like I don't know I just I felt like
before I had gone over overseas I was
like real like thank you for your
service to everyone I saw you know and
and afterwards I was just kind of the
opposite and I was like fuck all these
motherfuckers man so I was just
disgruntled in whatever and and people
you know I hear people talk about PTSD
or this or that and I'm like what the
fuck are you what are you afraid of you
know you were on a main base that like
it wasn't he it's not even a thing like
you didn't experience war but that was
like just kind of immaturity at the time
and and like like I said me being just
kind of disgruntled and dealing with
that and I was drinking like heavily and
I was just a super aggressive person and
it wasn't like a good it wasn't good for
my friends a family like people I cared
about whoever and like I said I felt
like seals were kind of the only ones
that understood and then even amongst
seals I felt like only the ones who who
had to live so shitty like we did like
our platoon you know no running water
for a year and like like just living in
that environment was super rough and I
felt like they were the only ones who
understood but then again it's like I
just spent a year with these assholes in
a hundred by a hundred foot you know
place I don't want to see them and so it
just kind of felt alone a little bit you
know and whatever dealt with that got
got through that and doing better now
and and I was like kind of disgruntled
towards people claiming PTSD and all
this kind of shit
for years after that and then actually
some random this random chick at a
dinner I was at she was in the Army or
something like that and and she had she
was talking about PTSD and I was just
thinking like Jesus Christ what the fuck
are you what what is it you know and I
kind of set my viewpoints on it and she
was like well you know fear is relative
and you know like you were you were
seriously trained and stuff for war and
and to be in that environment and you
know some people weren't and like fears
relative like this like being in a
gunfight to you you know in verses like
just being in that country like could be
the same amount of fear or more for that
person and I was just kind of like you
know hmm I never really thought about it
that way okay I'll change my mind yeah
well war is different for everybody and
it's I remember my first deployment to
Iraq we we we travel a lot and we went
to a lot of different places and so we
go from like the incredible palaces that
have been taken over that had subways
and Starbucks and then we you know the
next day we'd be out at some out station
somewhere there be an Oda team just
living in you know the most horrible
living conditions and then the next day
you'd be with some random Marine Corps
company out some other Forward Operating
Base and again they're just living like
in hell and then you come back to
another another like main fob and it's
all luxurious and nice and I mean it
just it kind of is what it is first you
know it just kind of is what it is and
that actually makes sense with that
theme
l said about you know hey it's the
different people are they're there
they're there for different reasons you
know like we joined the SEAL Teams
because what we want to do is go out and
go on patrol with a machine gun that's
like 100 percent right of why you joined
the SEAL Teams some of that goes you're
hoping for a fight like you're praying
for war
yeah and sure I remember like being out
there man I remember my very first up
when I we we flew into this to to this
village and I remember being like super
nervous and like holy shit I'm fucking
Navy SEAL and I'm actually going on my
first mission like holy shit and I'm
just thinking like when we land we
landed at like 3 a.m. or something and
that and we we offset like way far away
but I was thinking like it's gonna be
guns blazing as soon as this helo laughs
I jump out the he load and I'm just like
full-blown ready for war like what up
bring it on let's go where's Ben love
and it was just pitch black quiet and
sat there for fucking hours and you know
till the Sun came up nothing happened I
was like god damn it I was so
disappointed you know because I was
looking forward and like war and then
you know obviously we got we got plenty
yeah I yeah I remember just being real
antsy to to get in a firefight in you
know to to do what I've been trained to
do and put my training to the test you
know and yeah it's different for other
people who are not experienced is may
vary yeah there's no doubt about that so
did when you went to bat when you got
home and you got put into new platoon
did you guys keep a core group of guys
from your from your previous platoon
together or was it like brand new no no
we we had guys that stayed and and some
went you know to trade it and some
screen and standard tournament standard
shit few a few core guys stayed together
four or five or whatever
yeah and then you guys got a new chief
gonna do oh I see
yeah assistant to commander yeah yeah
that was man God thank I I am so I so do
not miss having fucking 20 bosses you
know in the military and then every you
know at the drop of a hat it can change
and then all of a sudden it's like nope
new flavor we're now we're you know it's
like Oh Jacko's now our fuckin commander
so we're all waking up at 4:30 and going
to PT it's like what the fuck when did
this happen
this is bullshit jack and as you get you
do another workup yep
and I always wanted to be a dog handler
this route and I I tried to volunteer to
be a dog handler as a new guy and they
said no you know they want you to go
yeah they want you to to here's your dog
names 48 and make it bark yeah so yeah
now I got to to do the dog handling
thing and was super super excited about
that and it was it was honestly such a
great time I had a badass dog and I was
his first handler and yeah it was it was
super cool because you know one I was I
was on one platoon wonder so I had
already kind of gotten that Afghanistan
gotten some combat under my belt and you
know I was the classic worst the worst
guy in the team's is a 1 platoon wonder
and so I was full-blown just water
cruise wondered you knew everything 100%
and and I got a fucking dog my dog was
super cool and they like they're the
there was six of us that went over to
work with the dogs and we all got along
really well and and that was super cool
because now you're not a new guy finally
you know and I mean even on our
deployment in Afghanistan we were still
fucking doing new guy shit you're here a
new guy you're fucking new guy I
couldn't fucking believe it
I'm like what we literally they've made
us shovel rocks one time they like a
whole like dumpster or dump truck full
of rocks and they just we just moved it
from one pile and just tent over like 10
15 feet to the right and we just moved
the pile of rocks to this make a new
pile 15 feet to the right and it was it
was a disciplinary thing it wasn't you
know all the new guys your attitudes not
good and we're just like are you fucking
serious like we were just in a firefight
with you like you know we're not like
we're expecting the like b-boys now and
they're like shut up new guys your
attitude sucks go shovel rocks and you
know we were like literally having to
burn shit you know burn our own shit we
had we had barrels that we had wrapped
up that cordon around and cut in half
and filled with diesel fuel and those
were our those were our shitters but
they needed burned so when when the when
the new guys you know when when we
didn't have the best attitudes or our
attitudes weren't up to par we shoveled
rocks and burn shit so I was definitely
happy to not be a new guy anymore here
but anyway yeah
so I won't between wonder had a dog and
got to go through another work up with
the dog so that was super cool and and
got to go through dog training school
and and learn about the dogs and and
yeah unfortunately like right right
before it was we were on like
pre-deployment leave and they had told
us like hey change of plans
we're going now we're going to you come
so we don't need the dog anymore
yeah and I was like fuck man this isn't
like a piece of equipment I mean that's
essentially how the Navy looks out of
them they are
they are equipment but you know
obviously it's a dog and you be you you
formed this like super strong bond and
attachment with them just like they're
your pet and my dog was super awesome
and I had worked with him so much you
know it's like a robot is like a it was
so cool and I was fucking so pissed off
when they just dropped that on us and
it's just like yeah they hand the leash
over to someone else and yeah so did
that and then went to you come and and
you know a lot of guys were fucking
super pissed off that we were going to
you come and you know I I was definitely
looking forward to using my dog and and
you know doing that in Afghanistan but
you know this is what it is you you know
I definitely knew that there wasn't I
didn't see any value in just bitching
about it and it seemed like that was
like the common thing was just it was it
seemed almost like if you weren't
bitching about it then you were looked
at as a turd and like if you you know if
you weren't bitching louder than the guy
next to you then you're you're you know
man I'm so just point we're not going to
Afghanistan
yeah me too I'm super disappointed like
yeah well I can't even sleep at night
you look well I don't even want to
fucking go you know like the you know
it's just yeah I just realized just to
shed some light up to everyone so when
you deploy in a seal platoon or a seal
troop you can deploy different parts of
the world sometimes you deploy to places
like Iraq and Afghanistan which as we
just kind of discussed that's where
everybody wants to go well 95 percent
well you never know what the real number
is there's something you don't wanna go
but there's there's the attitude most
guys want to go and they want to go
fight but there's also you have to
deploy to other parts of the world where
there's no war going on you might just
deploy to the Pacific or you might
deploy in this case you calm is for
European Command so that's going over to
Germany and doing doing things out of
Germany in different parts of Europe and
it's definitely not a high threat and
finally
and so yeah and and that's the way it
goes sometimes there's a mission that
has to be done and it's a different kind
of mission you're going to build
relationships with other countries and
you do these exercises and do training
events but it's not generally what guys
are excited to do in the SEAL Teams so
there's always there's always a you know
I always get asked that question what I
want to go and talk to seals is hey my
guys are going here how do I keep them
on you know how do I keep them how do I
keep them engaged when ya did no one
wants to do it or they don't care about
it and it's like yeah you got to work
through that it's definitely it's
definitely a challenge because you know
I would imagine especially if you know
like that you're going to you come and
then starting that work up because you
still have to go through the workup and
train as if you know your fucking life
depends on it and you're going to war
and you know that you're the elite you
know warrior and you have to be ready
for anything so you like obviously our
training is developed around that but
then having to keep up that motivation
like it's it's one thing when you're
like fuck t this training sucks and it's
I'm tired it's hot I'm you know like
fucking covered in shit or whatever and
I've got a hike twelve miles carrying
this thing and it's like well you got to
do it though because we're going to
fucking war like this serious you know
but then it's like why don't you come in
why the fuck are we even training today
I mean but I don't know so I didn't
really have that that attitude though I
was kind of excited to you know I had
just gotten we just done that that year
deployment to Afghanistan and it was you
know and my platoon was the one that was
really really shitty shitty living the
other two platoons were in Nice bases
that they were like had an awesome gyms
like good food and and stuff like that
and you know so I wasn't I wasn't too
terribly upset about it obviously like
everyone wants to go work and and kill
bad guys like a champion but
you know when you when you got to do it
that and it is what it is you might as
well fucking enjoy it that's why I feel
might as well make the most of it at
what point did you start jiu-jitsu I
started I started jiu-jitsu actually in
buds that was my introduction to buds
one of our buds instructors was he he
was interested in jiu-jitsu and liked it
or whatever and so as a punishment one
day we had to do wet and Sandy jiu-jitsu
like introduction to jiu-jitsu and like
a lot of guys were we're not enjoying it
because one if you've never done
jiu-jitsu you're 100% gonna get fucked
up by anyone who has done it
and we were wet in sandy so it was like
just cold and wet and miserable and
sandpaper like grinding on each other
you know but I actually really enjoyed
it I was like holy shit this is pretty
cool and one of the guys there was two
guys in our class that were both really
high level wrestlers like in high school
and um and they were probably like on a
blue belt level you know they were
probably like a hundred and thirty-five
hundred forty-five pounds and at the
time I was around 185 hundred ninety
pounds I'd done never done jujitsu ever
or wrestled or anything like that and I
always punched you know I knew a punched
hard cuz been in a lot of fights like
street fights and shit and bar fights
but at that point sorry I wasn't bar
fight so it was like high school fights
dodge ball fights okay I did get in a
dodge ball fight once no bullshit
and so anyway these these little guys
just tied me in a fucking not and I was
just so impressed like because I'm
looking at these dudes I would be like
100% I will fuck this guy up in a fight
and we you know they were like alright
no striking no no no punching but we're
gonna grapple like
and we're grappling and they're just
completely fucking me up and I was like
thinking oh my god if these little
itty-bitty men can tie me in a knot like
this and just make me helpless like
imagine what I could do if I learned
this
so I started rolling with one of my
friends who was like 6 to 240 pounds at
the time and just super aggressive and
he was probably around a blue belt level
of knowledge maybe not quite a blue belt
you know but he knew definitely more
than I did and we you know he was really
aggressive too and and and he was like
all about rolling so we would roll nogi
and he would just Constance was where I
this is it buds or Ian's buds and then
buds and then sqt
you know buzz was the introduction to it
and I was like well I can love this is
cool and then I started talking to one
of my classmates who is also into it and
you know he had done he had done some
training before the Navy and like I said
he was around a blue belt level so when
you got to team 10 did you start
training at media they're one of the
academies now I didn't start training at
one of the academies until after
Afghanistan I came back and because one
of the guys one of my like my C daddy he
was he was a purple belt at the time and
um we would roll on occasion you know in
and he would be like and he would tell
me like man you have like great you know
aggression and an ability in all this
shit but you got to go to an academy and
then learn you know I had only learned
just from that guy that dude beat my ass
over and over and he would literally
like just just fucking get on top
pressure grind arm triangle you know and
he'd be like all right man you know I
got on top you know fucking I'm trying
to I squeezed like that don't let me do
that again like all right got it yeah
try harder try harder you know you you
know you gotta do something
doing anything I mean so it was one of
those so I had gotten pretty good at
just getting my ass kicked and dealing
with a big large human or whatever so
then when I actually showed up to an
Academy I'd been doing that for a couple
years you know with him and never put on
a gear or anything like that but then
afterwards yeah he was like you got to
join gym so I joined a gym
put on the key and and then really like
that's when my jujitsu I say really
started my journey and that was in 2012
did you have someone to train with on
your EUCOM deployment um yeah
trained with my see daddy he was there
and I trained and you come like we were
obviously going to different countries
so I would go and hit up different gyms
and the different countries and then all
the other the other countries SEAL Teams
you know that we worked with there's
always someone who's in the combatives
you know so I would basically just find
out who that guy was
what's to get so yeah if he wants to get
some and then we'd roll the mats out and
fucking train and and I was trying to
get guys in that jujitsu
back then and I was telling them you
know it's a great workout and people
will just look at me like that's not a
fucking workout and you know you're not
lifting weights you're not running and
I'm like dude it is a workout for sure
and it's you know one that that I
thought the reason I liked jujitsu
specifically was because it was like a
deadly martial art you know I could
fucking choke you and like you're
tapping your you're asking me like
please don't kill me
you know and that's what I thought was
fucking cool about it and that is
definitely one of the cool things about
it you know like there's there's times
where I don't know you yeah like we're
we're gunfighters I get it but your
first line is should be you like my my
body what can I do with my fucking
vessel that I was brought into this
universe with like versus you if I don't
have a weapon if I don't
you know it's just me and you yeah
one-on-one like yeah I mean I got to see
like over and over again just guys that
didn't know how to didn't know anything
and they'd get in a simple prisoner
handling situation and wouldn't be able
to handle someone and the only thing
that they would know to do is like
bludgeon them in the head which is cool
that's fine I get it but when you bring
that person into the detainment facility
and they're freaking all jacked up and
then it turns out that they're not the
person you were looking for or whatever
and and that just doesn't that's just
not this is not cool and it's not it's
not tactically the best thing to do
because you don't have the control I
mean you can't count on punching someone
or hitting them in the head you can't
count on that solving the problem
whereas jiu-jitsu it's like ya know I
have this human under control whereas
you can you know you've punched people
before that you've nailed them and they
shook it off like it didn't even happen
you know the whole thing with like
muzzle strikes I've seen I've had guys I
mean I've muzzle struck plenty of people
but like I've had guys that I've seen
put the craziest most aggressive muscle
strike on a dude and have the dude
bleeding yeah but like still fighting
yeah I do think you're Enel ins a
fucking and so so yeah from the
especially when people are in fear for
their life oh yeah definitely
and they hate you and they hate your
society and they're a jihadist it's like
yeah they're that muzzle strike if it
doesn't knock him out what sure it is
possible but the idea that that was just
gonna stop someone and attract 100% of
the time was completely ludicrous now
with jiu-jitsu at least you're gonna
have some control more control and even
that's not a hundred percent you know
because you could you know you've got
someone that's really small against
someone that's really big and depending
on your skill level there could be
issues there but yeah so you finally
started training at a school yeah 2012
yeah they used of in all the way yeah I
started I started training at a school
in 2012 and
started competing in jiu-jitsu you know
I really once I once I joined a school I
learned more in six months than I did in
four years of course noogie rolling with
my buddies you know and I mean that is
just the blind leading the blind
essentially like who knows the most
today and it's like you guys are all
fucking wrong we're all teaching each
other wrong shit you know what I mean so
I learned more in six months and I did
that whole time and so I and at that
point I'd really like fallen in love
with jiu-jitsu and I started competing
all the time and was doing really well
because I was a I was competing as a
white belt you know but I had already
had a shitload of grappling experience
you know with fucking big strong dudes
who were just fucking me up but now like
now I'm the big strong guy and I know a
little bit and I've been in like hard
situations on the mat you know what I
mean and then obviously just the the
team guy just will to fight you know
that's always a different level and you
can tell when you roll with a teammate
even when a team guys brand-new at
jujitsu there's they're still going to
be there you can just tell that they're
different because their will to fight is
is generally higher yeah so anyway I
start competing a lot and doing really
well and then started fighting and doing
really well in that as well and then you
know that led me to what I'm doing now
and then you actually took over when you
came home from you you come to plum you
took over the combatives program yeah
yeah I I took over the combatives
program that was something that you know
I felt like kind of lacked in in the
SEAL Teams you know I was very shocked
at that I was surprised at that you know
obviously we're where the seals are the
best in the world you know at what we do
and you know we're gunfighters and and
all that shit but I would I imagined
that our hand-to-hand combat you know
like everyone thinks like oh if I can
see only must
you know tapped me on the shoulder and
I'll and I'll die you know and that's
true just for everyone's listening it's
definitely true but I hadn't gone to
that school yet so I was like confused
as to why that wasn't a school or
whatever so anyway I I felt like with at
this point I was I was competing quite a
bit and having having some pretty good
success in the fight MMA Jitsu world and
I'd also had you know real world
experience you know a lot of real world
experience dealing with prisoner
handling and stuff like that and um and
I just felt like I felt like I could
bring I felt like I could do a good job
at leading the combative so I took that
on board and and they gave me a shot and
I rewrote the curriculum for combatives
that we used on the on the East Coast
and it was it was really good you know
and and I went into with the
operationally focused mindset you know
not if if you're doing it I'm all about
jiu-jitsu I love jiu-jitsu however if
you're doing a triangle choke on target
something's probably gone terribly wrong
we roll you know but it's it's
definitely not a bad thing to know
jiu-jitsu you know what I mean
especially as an operator you're dealing
with human beings and you're not just
you know you're not just gonna go in and
fucking kill everyone on target you know
there it could that happen yeah
absolutely but is that gonna happen
probably not and you're gonna have to
deal with human beings and you know
anything from just marshaling them to a
full-on fight for your life is
combatives related you know so I covered
all of that in my program and and I
really focused on basic simple things
that you could remember during a time of
stress you know like you're not going to
remember
twelve steps to an armbar something like
that when you're in a situation and you
need it you know what I mean especially
in a combative situation overseas like
that's your Adrenaline's gonna be going
like crazy it's gonna be fast you need
something simple effective and that you
know that you can remember easily and
it's also you know it is like in a in a
workup you're you're getting fed through
a firehose essentially there's so much
shit you're you're learning and you're
expected to be proficient and like
perfect that all of it before you go out
the door
so our combative is we didn't get a
whole lot of time you know it's like a
two-week thing and so I I really focused
on developing techniques and things that
you know and would also be effective
effective towards your enemy or your
person that you were dealing with but
also mitigate risk to the operator you
know like muzzle strikes are great
because you can muzzle strike a hundred
people in a row and your hands feel fine
you know you're not worried about
breaking your weapons in control yeah so
you know that was kind of my focus was
operationally focused mindset and you
know and on the west coast I felt like
yeah from what I had seen going out
there and working with those guys it was
a lot of I felt like more guys were
interested in combatives but though it
was more of like a sporty kind of thing
like they were up in the fight room
doing jujitsu and stuff like that and
which at which I thought was great like
I said it's better it's definitely
better to to you know have it not need
it than he did not have it and so I
think that it was good that guys were
doing that but I didn't think that it
was operationally focused enough you
know like I don't think that you should
be training combatives and peaky gear
you know like I had my I liked the
program that I set up was all scenario
driven and it was all like train like
you fight you know so in your in your
camis in your boots
with your gear you know cuz handling
someone in PT gear versus handling
someone and you know full kit is totally
different as well yeah yeah well there's
it's uh you know I was the the
discussion that used to happen a lot
with all this stuff because believe me I
was in this discussion for a low
knowledge area on dive you you reach or
you get a ton of fuckin push man people
are super people are simple emotional
about and that about combatives and you
know I would always like I wasn't I
wasn't as emotional as I wasn't very
emotional about it but it for me it was
just like hey guys need to know how to
do this this is this isn't about emotion
this is about just the facts of being
ready to be prepared
being prepared on the battlefield that's
what you need to be and you know one of
the things that people would say was you
know the like the speed shooting
contests you shouldn't do that because
it'll take away from your operational
capability okay I get it
however who does better on the range the
guy that's like a hobby shooter too and
then goes out to whatever CQC he's
drilling nails all day long the same
thing with parachuting like okay so I
skydive whatever I'm a I'm a skydiver on
the weekends and I like to go down and
have a ton of jumps I have you know
2,000 jumps with my slick rig how do i
do and i put a combat equipment on I do
awesome I'm Way better than like a guy
like me because I wasn't like a
recreational skydiver whenever I put
equipment on it was like it was it was a
I had to pay attention whereas the guys
that were good skydivers in the civilian
side they were good same thing with like
Oh who's gonna do better in a in a
grappling match a guy that wrestled in
high school with his gear on or a guy
that didn't you know has his gear on
it's like it doesn't matter you get
certain skill level and you're gonna do
great and that's just the way it is now
what you can't do is just say oh well
we're never gonna train with gear on
because there are certain
you know it's like saying hey we're
never gonna train with Iggy if you if
someone never trained with Aggie before
and they go against some of the key it
depends on how long that person's been
training with Aggie for because hey
noogie and key have all kinds of
similarities they have all kinds of
similarities they also have some
differences and depending on how much
you do of each is where you're gonna
kind of shake out which one you're
better at but there are there so much
crossover between key and no key between
skydiving on the weekends and skydiving
in the teams and shooting on the
weekends and shooting of the teams the
way I always looked at it was train more
train exact training all the time with
everything he Oh as much as you can and
that's that's how you get better at
things but yeah that combatives thing
was um it still is it still is I know
it's it's it's hard it's hard to change
it's a it's a taboo thing for some
reason and and it totally depends on
who's who's at the head of the table
yeah you know what what their flavor is
what their take is on it and if the guy
you know is like you or me and then it's
like hey we're all gonna fucking we all
need to notice we only do it and then
other guys come in they're like oh that
shit's stupid we don't need that yeah
and I was I was when someone would say
guys should be working on shooting I'd
say you know I totally agree absolutely
you know give us a range you know in the
building and we'll do that in the
building because that's without question
our primary weapon system and you know
no doubt I you want to be a great shot
for sure
guess what how many hours are you gonna
shoot a day yeah I mean are you gonna
shoot 22 hours a day cuz you're gonna
have some time at some point we go you
know what let's get some other skills in
here you know we might as well know and
like you said earlier you can't just go
you don't just go on target and shoot
everyone there's a there's a female you
know Dave Burke who's one of the guys at
national on front good - yeah he has a
he has a story that he tells about the
first time he came face to face with
like Iraqi woman that did not want him
in the house and he's you know whatever
a 18 year Marine at this point and he
didn't know what
to do yeah and it's like yeah you you
you need to train you need to train to
handle those situations and and a lot of
people you know the people are
unpredictable
they sure are just totally unpredictable
and especially in a situation where they
don't know like a bunch of people with
guns and body armor just busted up in
their fucking house like do you think
that person's gonna be like just cool as
a cucumber or calm like I don't know and
then when you put hands on people two
people freaked the fuck out and and you
know and you don't need to just muzzle
strike everyone like you said like if
you do that you're gonna get shut down
real quick they're gonna mean and you
should be as an elite warrior you should
be expected or at least I expect people
to handle themselves like and you
shouldn't let this fucking Iraqi woman
just walk all over you or fucking flail
around because like you don't know what
to do I can't
muzzle striker I can't shoot her so what
do I got to do you know what I mean and
if you've never and that's just like a
woman but if Letta now you have like a
fighting age male or something and you
know oh if he resists I'll just kill no
it's not the case always you know it's
definitely not like and you know it's
you definitely don't want the first time
that you're handling a human being like
that to be overseas when it's real and
they can you know very easily get to
your shit on your kit and you know it
can be a bad day especially like I tell
people you know just think of like
muzzle muzzle discipline and awareness
you know like when you have your gun
even at high ready and then you're
marshalling someone and they freak the
fuck out now all of a sudden you've got
a hot weapon like going around the room
it's just shit that there's so much
things that you you need to think about
and the more you do it the more
comfortable you're gonna be with it and
that was kind of my mindset towards it
at what point did you realize you were
gonna get out
well I wasn't I wasn't sure I was
fighting and stuff and I was just kind
of doing that as as for fun as a hobby
on the weekends and competing and stuff
like that and then I gone out and
trained at Black House with some UFC
fighters and I had over it I had always
like looked at the UFC you know as I was
I was always a fan and I enjoyed
fighting and stuff and but I'd always
looked at those guys like they were kind
of superhuman or like like it was like
the NFL of fighting like those guys are
genetic freaks or whatever you know what
I mean when you think of someone in the
NFL you're just like man it must be nice
to be born like that you know or
whatever
what Fighting's kind of a unique thing
where I don't know anyone can do it and
as long as you just put in the the work
you know what I mean so and being a
genetic freak helps too
but uh but I'd gotten there I got in the
black house and I trained with some of
the people in the UFC and I was just
like holy shit like I'm actually like
doing fine like I'm hanging with these
guys and and um you know talking to them
and and just kind of getting to know
some of these guys and just made it a
little more human you know it's like
well what did you do before you were
fighter like oh I fucking worked at a
restaurant you know I was a busboy or
whatever I was you know this that third
and I was just thinking you know and
they're all looking at me like dude
you're fucking Navy SEAL like and I'm
just like yeah but that's all I've ever
known that's all I've ever done I did
right out of high school you know and uh
and I'm just me you know and I know like
I'm not special you know I mean and it
just kind of made a head of like a shift
or like a realization like these are
just people just like you and and they
just fucking stuck with fighting and
practiced it until they were good enough
to beat you know the competition and
they're here and I was like fuck I I can
do that like I'm pretty good you know
and yeah and I've been through some shit
like I could push myself hard like fuck
I can do this and at the time like I was
are I'd already been a seal for a while
and and you know I got to experience a
ton and life and just in war and and
just that whole lifestyle and that whole
thing and and I was just out of
crossroads you know and I was like well
I can stay in and make a career out of
this like I was planning on doing I was
planning on staying in for 20 years
and you know I can screen and you know
try and make it over there and or I can
get out and and kind of pursue this and
and at the time I was 29 or yeah I was
27 when I was like making this decision
and um I was like you know fighting is
kind of a young man's game and like you
read earlier in the beginning of this
like can't you can't even pause time you
know waits for no one
and I was like well if I if I just keep
down this road I I don't want to think
like what if or like regret you know and
I was like I've already I've already
been on this path for a while and and
it's cool and all that but I want to see
what else I can do so I and I was really
fucking struggling with with that
decision for a long time as stressing me
out and then once I just said fuck it
and this decided you know which way I
was going then the like all that stress
like relief this it was a big reliever
and yeah decided to get out and there
were you what year was out I got out in
2018 and how many amateur fights did you
have when you were in
like 17 or something and then and did
you go pro while you were still in no
they wouldn't let me and that was like
it was so frustrating to me because in
Virginia the amateur rule set is the
exact same as pro so it's day before
weigh-ins you know all strikes like no
Sherman ellos no shin pads
you know it's four ounce gloves no
headgear you know it's it's it's a it's
fucking Pro or five-minute rounds now
there were three that's three four three
minute round three little roads or
three-minute rounds but some some of
them had five-minute rounds like gonna
fountain North Carolina so yeah it was
no different you know and trying to
explain that to like my command and shit
and I'm like there is literally no
difference and a guess what like a punch
from punch in the face from an amateur
feels the same I'm a pro that's what
I'll tell you what like those that
bruise that came from an amateur would
have came from a pro to do what I talked
to Tim Kennedy about this like it's so
crazy
the army gave that guy and gives him
someone he's a great guy and obviously a
credible fighter but yeah I mean he was
just full-on just get he after it read
well he still is
yeah and they supported yeah he's all
it's awesome they awesome date man I ran
into total fucking roadblocks left and
right with my fighting and you know and
I used the argument all the time like
guys you don't mean stay the same way
Brian stay yeah he was in the Marine
Corps yeah I just a brave officer of the
Marine Corps just out there fight in the
WEC but the fucking boat race Tim
Kennedy they they sponsored him yeah
yeah it's like Ranger up or whatever
yeah well Rangers up is it's actually
Tim's comp company no Tim but for a
while Tim Tim was like he I forget the
exact story but he he was sponsored by
like the army yeah for a while we were
using it as like a recruiter yeah and
then he said listen you can either keep
paying me a sponsorship or you can just
let me come back on active duty and and
they were like that sounds like a good
financial bu for us so yeah Tim Tims
yeah and that's and that
why I kind of was forced to choose
because I was running into so much
fucking bullshit there and you know like
glory glory had come to town and they
were doing a fight at the Hampton
Coliseum and you know at this point I
had already had quite a quite a few
fights under my belt and had some
popularity I guess as a fighter and and
they had heard about me and they invited
me to fight on the show and mike tyson
was gonna be there and shit and i was
like man this is gonna be a fucking huge
opportunity it's on Spike TV too and I
was you know I was like can I can I
fight on this and and then you know
we'll we'll see what we can do blah blah
blah and then last you know last minute
they they told me no you know and I was
just like fuck if I would have been your
boss you would have been fight I know
and that's the shitty part is like you
know it depends on who who's at the at
the table at the moment
babies know now that I think about it
because I'm just sitting here thinking
like there's probably a fact I remember
seeing some kind of policy that they put
in place at some point I forget even
would see if it was yes or no I forget
remember but my argument to that was
like all the time was like like just
same one with the skydiving you know I'm
like guys fucking skydive all the time
there's leapfrogs you know why not why
don't the Navy why doesn't the Navy use
me as a recruiting tool you know like I
wouldn't I don't want to get out of the
team's yeah I I want to stay in the
teams but I also want to fight and like
I can do this like I was ranked number
one on the East Coast in two weight
classes you know and I was like I'm
pretty good at this shit like you know
and it I don't understand why we don't
utilize this utilize me as a recruiting
tool you know go to the fights set up a
fucking pull up bar hand out t-shirts
and dry and hand you know or go to the
thing they had me go to the national
high school wrestling contest or
tournament and they had me do like a
combatives demonstration and
and had me go out there and wrestle with
all the the high school students and
yeah fucking brought it yeah I'll tell
you what probably the you know I was up
at the California State Championships
last year or no it was 2019 yeah bunch
of hyenas well yeah I mean my daughter
was competing and but you know we're up
there and the boys they're just animals
they're animals it's it's awesome to see
ya
yes it's those kids were fucking tough
oh yeah and they fucking they all wanted
some yeah they were like and and cuz I
was there in like Cammy Cammy pants you
know and the fucking blue UDT seal
shirts and and we brought the pull-up
bar and and you know cuz the I think but
buds likes they try to get wrestler
server because wrestlers you know
wrestlers I don't even want to say
wrestlers have a good chance of making
it through buds because that's not true
it's definitely not true a slightly
better transited normal right however
however wrestlers are used to a fucking
grind and that's probably why they're a
little bit more comfortable and used to
the grind factor of buds that does not
mean they're used to getting cold and
wet and dealing with all that shit but
they're used to dealing with the grind
so whatever and they're competitive so
so we went there and yeah all those all
these fucking high school wrestlers are
looking at me like I got something to
prove you know or whatever and and I'm
out there representing the fucking SEAL
Teams I'm like I got something proved
too let's go young buck and so we we
know it was a good time but I was like
why don't they fucking they're cool with
this but not like fighting like what's
the difference like I don't know so I
just ran into tons of frustrating
headaches like that and that's what
ultimately decided to you know I was
just decided to go go this way and I'm
glad I did but and that's what you know
I gotta say like the SEAL Teams I never
tried to fight pro but like the SEAL
team it was totally support like I would
go and train at places they'd give me
well
less customers there are a lot different
in these guys you guys were definitely
more supported on that kind of stuff
extracurricular so you get out and then
when did you go pro right after here I
got out so you've been pro for me a year
and a half two years right yeah yeah
yeah but how many fight pro fights do
you have I've only done two pro fights
so far I won my first one by TKO in the
third round it was a good really good
fight against another pro who he was a
pro boxer as well and he had called me
out and kind of campaigned for the fight
or whatever and cool so I pledged and
and then and then I did my LFA debut I
fight in a Sun gun I don't know if
you've seen any pictures or videos I
mean I have unfortunately seen their you
can't unsee it so that's actually my
buddy Jeff gum he owns that company yeah
so so obviously like I try to support
other team guys and and their ventures
and stuff like that and you know I'm
that was right up my alley with the I
thought it was funny I'll pretty much do
anything if I think it's funny and so I
fought in the Sun go which is for those
you don't know it's kind of looks like a
American flag diaper sort of thing but
it's sex yeah well it's from Brazil in
Brazil there's a Sun gun there's a Sun
gal and I think this Sun guys like the
smaller one and the Sun Gow is like a
little bit but they're their speedos
yeah essentially so their speedos and
Dean Lister because he has so much
Brazilian influence in his brain he went
through his phase of training with a
song Gao and and that those are some of
the worst years of my life don't know no
itself we can't do that today
yeah so I'm not a very anti Sangha and
some Gao well but you you know you go
for it well I de it's if if I wouldn't I
would make me want to fight you les
yeah if you were wearing that so you got
that little psychologic or it was like
confusing to them yeah you know we just
mean did you let were you watching like
UFC when everyone was when all the
Brazilians were still wearing them in
UFC and they still do sometimes yeah
yeah I've seen some yeah anyways but I
thought it was funny so I so I got a
little patch sewn into it so I could put
my cup in it and that was my my new
fighting attire and yeah I went out it
couldn't have
I don't it was awesome will say that I
went out I fought on LFA on national TV
and I would it was during a Military
Appreciation fight and so we did they
hosted the fight at an army base and it
was in a hangar you know with
helicopters and we've got all these
people all these active duty army people
in their uniforms and stuff in the crowd
and you know Here I am the the Navy SEAL
and the American flag speedo and and
come out to fight and got knocked out
thirty seconds so I was like get really
that much worse from here so that's cool
but now it was it was actually they
called it the craziest 31 seconds in LFA
history yeah I watched it I watched it
it was no I don't have a lot of time to
watch fights yeah I had time for life
yeah oh yes I saw a link I think you
posted it somewhere else yeah I mean
which some which so many people were
were soaked like they were like wow I
can't believe you posted this and they
sat him down first right didn't you sit
him down no so he had a 14-inch reach on
me he's 663 and fucking big-ass dude and
honestly like I didn't even know like we
were we were real cordial with each
other like at weigh-ins and stuff like
that so I wasn't sure if like we were
gonna touch gloves or not you know
because it's always kind of a I feel
like they should just like make that
a rule like ure you you either do or you
don't it's a rule with me now but I
wasn't sure if we were gonna touch
gloves or not and like kind of coming
out dude he honestly he hit me like I
didn't even know he could reach me from
where he was and it was just like I
think from that that that big wake I do
a big weight cut and I think it just you
know just fucking just put me on queer
Street right away and so right out of
the gate side I was rocked and and was
kind of fell down and was just getting
he'd swarm me and I was just getting
punches thrown at me left and right and
I'm just kind of like seeing stars
trying to gain my composure and then I
finally like got backed up in into one
against the cage and and gained my
composure for a second landed a one
clean one two and dropped him and then
ran over like got excited when I dropped
him down kind of went over towards him
and and fucking just I think probably my
coordination was just kind of off still
from just getting rocked and and I
literally just tripped right over head
over him over his body and then as we're
both standing up he fucking threw
another punch and that was it so and
then I was just like god damn it I'm a
fucking Navy SEAL on a army base like
fighting an American flag speedo a
national TV and just got knocked the
fuck out yeah I don't know what to tell
you yeah no that's that's a man you're
getting out there hey yeah there's gonna
be a winner to loser that's ain't and if
you the real losers are the ones that
are actually not getting in the ring
yeah you know a lot a lot more times
than that I've come out victorious so it
is what it is I don't it didn't slow me
down
doesn't bum me out or whatever just part
of it and I I understand that going into
it
it's a risk I'm willing to take yeah
what's your next fight we're setting up
one
looking at August 25th in Riverside
hopefully with the LFA so hopefully that
goes through and and I'll be all set to
go
ready I do a little boater yet now I
don't care who it is just I just want
someone yeah I don't care like I I never
really care who my opponent is honestly
I don't I don't look at really their
skill set or I never have really I don't
care because I've dealt with people just
so much and like combatives and and
jujitsu and fighting it's just like
people are unpredictable and that's what
I stick with like you may think you have
a game plan figured out and then all of
a sudden they do something different and
I don't even want to be thinking about
oh well I thought he was gonna do this
and I had this set up for this and you
know what I mean like I I know what you
mean I will say this when you find out
who your opponent is you got to watch
him you got to watch some you gotta at
least figure out because there's people
that have things they have their game
and if they have that game and you and
you know about it as you know like if if
you know I'm good at whatever you'll
defend that thing right and if you don't
know it well then I'll get you in that
situation right if you really looks like
what welcome to anybody anybody if you
everyone's got that thing at their game
that they're good at right and like in
jiu-jitsu hey this guy's got a good
guillotine this guy's got a good arm
lock this guy's got good heel hooks or
whatever everyone's got their little
thing and if they're good at it
then that's what they'll kind of steer
you towards but yeah so I was in I
always say look I get it
we don't care the opponent is but when
you find out who your opponent is take a
look you know sit send it to me let me
look at you know what I mean because
like I've been watching these things
forever
to say hey looks like this guy's got
this and you also have to watch more
than you know to watch like three or
four fights and see if they have any
grappling tournaments that are posted on
Naga or whatever on YouTube you know you
find out what kind of game they have and
if you can do that then you can learn
from it and you can take it into the you
can take it into the cage with you yeah
now I I'm definitely not opposed to
doing that at all I just I just don't
put all my eggs in the pusher you know
what I mean that way I don't if if shit
doesn't go according to plan like that's
cool because they're just off - yeah -
evolve but guess what they'll go back -
they'll go back to what they're good at
your and I mean so that's another thing
to think about and cool I saw that glory
that actual story when I had gotten told
no that I wasn't able to do that fucking
event in in Hampton Roads so I was
really bummed out and so I ended up
actually just calling I already like had
decided at that point I was like you
know it fucked this I'm getting out of
the Navy like I'm I don't want I don't
want to be told what I can and can't do
or whatever you know what I mean like
and so I called the the guy back and
said well when's it in next one
and he was like oh we got it we got
another another one coming up in San
Diego and I said put me on that one and
I so I just took leave and was I am I'm
just going to San Diego and I ended up
fighting in the glory here in San Diego
I just took leave and and went out there
and did it anyway and ended up knocking
the guy out in the second round right
off that's pretty good outcome well this
is a pretty good spot since we're up to
current events what else I know you got
your supplement company you got t-shirts
what else how can people support what
you got going on I would say the biggest
biggest way is probably on Instagram
that's my really my only platform I put
out a lot of content on Instagram I do
my live streams from there I thought
about doing a podcast as well but but I
think I'm just gonna stick to my
Instagram lives and just kind of treat
them as podcasts or whatever because I
like talking and interacting with with
my supporters a lot and you know so and
I figure people get bored just talking
to me for a long time in a room like
this I don't know
but uh yeah I would say follow me on
instagram at at mitch Aguiar and yeah
we've got a supplement company our main
product is a thing called the smashing
greens it's what I gave you today yeah
and that that actually is a blend of
different organic superfoods so I
watched this documentary called fat sick
and nearly dead I don't know if you've
seen it or not I haven't thought it's on
Netflix and uh this guy he he was really
overweight and had this some sort of
skin disease and he ended up getting a
juicer and ended up doing 60 days of
just vegetable juice and he ended up
losing a ton of weight and his skin
disease cleared up and just like the
doctors were just like blown away at at
how healthy he had become you know just
from from doing all this and learned
about micronutrients and all this stuff
so I was like man that seems like a cool
cool thing like I want to try it you
know I've never fasted before or
anything like that and I went out and
bought a juicer and it was it was
fucking pain in the ass to clean that
thing like three times a day and I was
having I had to buy like $30 worth of
vegetables every day to make enough
juice to you know put into a glass that
would somewhat keep me full and I was
just like there's gotta be a better way
than this shit and so ended up going to
a vitamin shop and saw like organic
freeze-dried wheatgrass you just add
water to and I was like oh my god that's
so much better you know so I went and
basically picked out a bunch of
ingredients that I did research on that
you know things that I wanted and and
put them all into like a shaker cup and
added water and drank it and did did a
fast that way and it was obviously much
cheaper much better like just more
convenient
everything like that and I just didn't
have anything in a post on Instagram one
day and and so I just shared it I was
just like hey this is kind of a
concoction that I came up with and and I
do my I do a 5 day fast like this and
just kind of it makes me feel good it
helps me lose weight and then I started
doing that like cutting weight for my
fights and and then people it just
fucking caught on like wildfire like
everyone was like what is that what is
that and then I was like look I'm not
associated with these companies at all
you know like these aren't I don't get
it paid for this like this is just here
this is what I do and like put it laid
it all out there
and it's like you can get all these
products on Amazon or your local vitamin
shop or whatever and just made it as
idiot proof as I could and I was just
getting bombarded with questions
non-stop but but it was like a lot of
people were having like a ton of success
fasting with that and losing weight so I
was like well that's pretty cool you
know like I'm really I'm down to help
people you know better themselves and I
enjoy like pushing people and pushing
myself and trying to be better and
everything so so I stuck with it and
just kept kept answering all the
questions or whatever and then after
like a year and a half or so I ended up
making my own you know it's just like
well I might as well fucking make this
my own product and so I found a way to
to kind of make that come to life and
took all those products basically and
just put them into one removed all the
fillers and all the bullshit in there
and just I was like you know I didn't
know anything about the supplement
industry or anything like that I just
never intended on non doing that but it
just kind of came about and you know
delivered a product that was way more
convenient and everyone was already
using and buying all these other things
and now now it's like my product and
they're able to support me and now it's
like I don't you know I don't have an
issue answering these questions now that
you're buying my product you know what I
mean so
now it's it's been super awesome because
we've had just a ton of people lose so
much weight and like my brother lost 110
pounds you know using that so it really
works which is cool you know and and
it's really helpful for people and
changing their lives and like I'm all
about that and now like it's supporting
me financially now that I'm not out you
know in the Navy anymore because I
didn't I didn't get a retirement or
anything like that I just got out so so
yeah that's super cool and the
supplement in company but now that I've
been in it for a little while like I'm
starting to get more understanding of it
and and we're we're doing pre-workout
protein BCAAs and all that stuff like
kind of expanding it and and you know
now I'm like really involved with it and
and I'm just treating it like everything
else like I always tried to you know
under-promise and over-deliver and like
I always want to make sure that like
people are getting like a something good
you know I don't want to ever feel like
I won or got one over something like
that like when people come to use my
products like I want them to be like a
fucking satisfied there for sure it
means that's the best policy to have
make the best yeah so just don't skimp
you know like my my my end game is not
to make the most profit like I want an
actual good fucking product like that my
name's behind you know and I'm proud of
what's the what's the website you can
either go to smashing frog dot-com or
massive supplements calm mas F
supplements calm either when they go to
the same place but yeah and we got
t-shirts and stuff but I'm I'm basically
streamlining my t-shirts because I had
massive apparel and I just made a bunch
of t-shirts that that I wanted to make
you know that were like personal to me
like the mindset
everything attitude is contagious don't
be a pussy be humble you know these are
shirts that like I've kind of made all
the shirts that I want to make and I
made him I was kind of a t-shirt snob
before I had my company and then once I
made my company and like got into the
apparel industry like I just wanted like
really comfortable nice fitting good
quality t-shirts and printed my own shit
on them and that's all I wear now but
I'm just streamlining it down to a
couple that I like and I'm actually
launching a new brand pretty soon that
I'm very excited about : cool right over
there so if you follow me on instagram
you'll you can keep up with all that
stuff I got going on and and watch my
future fights and hopefully I don't get
knocked out echo you got anything what
happened with that dodgeball fight
you're talking about oh man it was oddly
enough it was in a church also so I got
into a dodgeball Church fighting
dodgeball Church would you win that one
I did right knock the guy's teeth out um
we we were there to practice our
dodgeball and um we were taking it very
seriously
you know because there was a tournament
coming up that I think had like a $500
prize which when you're like sixteen
five hundred dollars is yeah that'll go
along go a long way so you know the
stakes were high and we were we're we
were there and there was some local
jokers that were just you know not
taking it seriously and like just
fucking with our practice and stuff and
dude if there's one thing that makes me
angry legitimately angry is when people
are taking dodgeball says it was there
was a time for joking around there was a
time for seriousness and you know that
wasn't the time and ended up you know I
ended up saying something to this dude
and just just kind of fucking mouthed
off and you know my tempers tempers
flared and escalated yeah things
escalated and ended
get into like a full-on brawl laying on
the husband's game bro as a judge brawl
it's time to crawl thank you well
awesome um
hey speaking of fighting sure and
smashing things sir I mean echo yes we
want to be better at fighting we want to
be better at living what do you got what
do you got for us I had a few things so
we'll start with jiu-jitsu right like
you know be better I'm starting to like
noogie better I would say just because I
feel like it's more applicable to the
cage however you know I like jock I was
saying earlier I agree wholeheartedly I
think that everyone who trains jiu-jitsu
should train in Aggie as well because
you know there are a lot of similarities
and I feel like if you only train nogi
and then you go against someone with a
put Aggie on with any sort of decent
skill level you're gonna get fucking
choked for sure yeah and it just the
ghee slows everything down and it's a
it's a totally different animal and the
thing is like you can train in Agee all
the time and take the ghee off and roll
with someone no ghee and you're you're
gonna do fine you're still doing
jiu-jitsu you know what I mean it's a
different game but it's not that much
different but going from noogie to ghee
very different so that's why I think I
think people should definitely train in
Agee still yeah agree yeah both is best
for sure
yeah the GI adds these elements that if
you only train nogi you're not used to
those elements and if someone else is
used to those elements all the nogi out
well most of the nogi elements are in
the ghee you know like those elements
are there for the most part of course
clothes you know like using like an if
you were getting a street fight like you
can use clothes like a ghee right so it
gives you even that many more options
yeah for sure yeah
agree well speaking of geez well G we're
gonna get everyone's doing jiu-jitsu no
I feel like it's growing essentially
so what kind of gear we getting or Jinky
you know why are we getting or gingy's
because they're made in America and they
are factually the best skis in the world
rash guards as well okay so where do we
get and we get them at origin Maine
dot-com that's also where we're getting
genes yeah and by the way and I got mine
by the way approval level 100 you know
I'm always reluctant to sing you know
hundred one percent approval but here
I'm gonna say it one hundred one percent
approval because they exceeded literally
exceeded my expectations your
expectations were high worried a hundred
percent I was like yeah the way you're
talking the way I think you know PD does
a good job in building these things up
you know he's taking close-up pictures
of the buttons coming out of the factory
that is it's really good so I'm like
alright expectation expectation level is
high
100% these have to be five-star genes
essentially they're like five star plus
some added things that I was impressed
with so yes 100 101 percent approval yes
so genes you can get them t-shirts rash
guards supplement up supplements yes so
what kind of supplements joint warfare
mmm which I'm happiest man I've been on
the joint Wharf I think it's been one
year consistent joint warfare krill oil
so approved 100% of Peru actually adding
value providing value even beyond what
you might think in the beginning because
you know one you know when we're young
you know we're all young guys or
whatever you don't care that you know
you have muscle soreness you have all
this stuff where the joint soreness is
one of those things that just kind of
creeps up on you but if you're on top of
that that doesn't take it you don't take
you out of game if you're not ready
preventative yeah and when it comes
about I'd get like elbow stuff from
lifting and stuff but if if I was on
like joint warfare glucosamine
chondroitin any any one of these things
that they did recommend when I started
grappling by the way if I was on that I
would have never got out of the game
yeah at any point unless the point is
get your joint more fair get your krill
oil and stay on that get your discipline
to fully get your discipline discipline
is like all day now yes sir that's kind
of where it's going it's yeah it's like
guess what I'm just drinking oh I'm just
gonna have some discipline right it's
how you poured this
is this what you're talking yeah yeah
it's just hastiness and goodness free
mission is this a pre-workout yeah it's
it's not like a super um yeah there's
not like a super caffeinated deal cuz I
don't drink a lot of caffeine and I
don't want to drink a lot of caffeine so
yeah you little cognitive a little
physical okay and you and you just sip
this all day yeah I have like some and
then I won't drink it like after dinner
you know because I there's a little bit
of caffeine in it and I don't drink a
lot of caffeine so not even in the
mornings when you when you're waking up
no there's a little bit i have ct2 the
white tea has some caffeine in it too so
I guess I do drink caffeine but I don't
drink high doses like like a like a
monster energy drink or whatever yeah it
makes this peak of energy drink we got
our energy but no but it's it's actually
good for you
which is completely it's like we it's
hard to call it an energy drink because
energy drink puts it in a in a category
with things that are actually horrible
for you yeah right like there's normal
energy drinks that are just horrible for
you this is something that you can
legitimately just drink and it's good
for you yeah so that's coming out you'll
see some cans of that in the near future
oh yeah that's the good Oh awesome milk
mm-hmm you want a dessert if you want
extra protein in the form of the dessert
that's it monk all flavors I like that
to say if you want to use or even me
chocolate yes I have a mint chocolate
protein as well and I was my my protein
or my supplements took a long time to
come out like wait I'm sure if you've
encountered whenever you're dealing with
any kind of putting out something never
goes according to plan as always longer
than you're expecting or whatever and I
had done a mint chocolate die that was
just I've been a huge fan of mint my
whole life mint chocolate whatever
deliciousness
and I saw that you put out a mint
chocolate and I was like god damn it
everyone is gonna think I copied or
they'll probably think like dang I
thought I was the only one who love mint
chocolate better than everything else
like yeah well we all kind of do me
Jocko with bow seals both like jujitsu
both like mint chocolate yeah well same
thing with Pete
right I mean not another name seal thing
but wait was he into mint chocolate or
peanut butter he was into men but I
think peanut butter see the peanut
butter was kind of like though yeah I
don't wear well I started smashing well
yeah and that makes sense because in my
family you know I'm not there scar like
my favorite dessert is this or that I'm
not that you know but I will say that
when you came out it's almost like you
know you're you're going public with
your mint chocolate love admiration I
was like eh hey me too but peanut butter
chocolate has always been my close close
second yeah easy money but the one that
really the strawberry because it's just
so yeah good oh yeah but it strawberry's
a staple anyway you know it's like they
know everything but sounds vanilla but
I'm not over here I'm not over here
jumping up and down about vanilla yeah
but some people I know some people are
okay I've got a cinnamon toast crunch
looming out and I've got to think of a
name for it because okay I don't think I
can legally call it cinnamon toast
crunch
I thought about thinking of you know
growing up I always had we were kind of
not so financially
gifted yeah I'm gonna call it that
whatever living in a trailer yeah my mom
would always get fruity Dino bites you
know there you go and cinnamon toast
glares that's not what the other kids
once I once I joined the Navy and
started getting you know a good paycheck
I just I never you know I never again I
always appreciated my cereal game it was
always
good real stuff fruity pebbles there's
no fruity Dynamite's in this house get
out of here with that little kids need
food that's where I got warrior kid milk
strawberry boom chocolate yeah let them
eat and be healthy got that yeah yeah
yeah my wife gets lit like she hits a
point in the day where she's like man
I'm considering just to go to bed right
now or two busts out a jock a white team
just get a physician literally says that
decision yeah and I know the feeling but
man she's really committed to it don't
go to you gotta take something or make
create a supplement of some kind for a
little power nap because working order
you know I did start a rumor that you
take naps no I freely admit that yeah
open about it I realize I wrote about uh
in the discipline goes freedom field
manual yeah I mean if I'm really tired
I elevate my feet above my heart and I
set an alarm and I'll sleep for eight
minutes and and eight minutes eight
minutes
yeah or now yep and if you go I mean
sometimes I'll go ten but if you start
going 15-20 then you then you're like
legitimately you'll feel groggy but you
know the deal man from like you were
talking about sleeping in a helicopter
like you wake up from those things
you're totally on fire you know sleep
for ten minutes eight minutes whatever
so yeah I'm I have no problem with this
I the problem with me is I don't know
i eyes tend to nap better than i sleep
and then like when i when i wake up my
brain just starts going and i just once
that happens it's just that's a i'm up
so when you say a supplement for power
naps it like helps you get into like
power nap state like that guy i don't
know working it
it could be secure ear cinnamon toast
crunch flavored situation have you taken
hypnose oh yeah so origin so we have we
have this thing called hypnose which is
like asleep but yeah but that's not for
now and you need some good nor eight
minutes
it's you take a rail of it and you're
out for eight minutes just fully reach
out and work out or nap I'm working on
it well wait but technically and I don't
know this just seems like this is true
power nap okay you know you have like
what the five phases right of sleep yeah
or six piracy insomnia yeah so yeah so
you can have so you probably jet get
jammed up somewhere in one of those
stages right power nap is stage one I
think I'm pretty sure it's only stage
one power nap that depends on how tired
you are well then it won't be considered
a power nap if you're like super tired
and you go boom all the way faith Stage
five sleep right you went to yeah do you
have sleep apnea or anything no no yeah
I don't have I did a sleep study and I
don't have sleep apnea but I have
insomnia and it's like I wake up enough
not to actually wake me up but like it's
a like I wake up don't even know I'm
awake oh you know what I mean so I wake
up when I do wake up I'm fucking still
exhausted yeah it's great
so one of the I actually have a CBD line
as well which I don't know if if you get
into the CBD at all not really no no but
one of the products that that we're
launching is a thing called green dreams
and it's a rapid dissolve it's a rapid
dissolve tablet you put on your tongue
and dissolves in like 10 seconds and
it's 25 milligrams of CBD and 10
milligrams of melatonin so but that's
that's not for an 8-minute yeah a power
nap power nap that's the green of bed
situation it's there have to go to bed
nighty-night right on well the opposite
of that is jock whitey cuz you don't
take that before you go to bed maybe
after you wake up in the middle of the
day like my wife or whatever also if
you're into deadlifting which we all are
of course it'll increase it to 8,000
pounds proven by the way double-blind
triple placebo situation no joke also we
have our own store chocolate store it's
called choco store we got rash guards
room service yeah t-shirts you want to
represent while on the path the Rutgers
hats yeah for those of
that like like truckers hats which
apparently we do they're nice
one-size-fits-all door what about flex
fit reflex fit for a while but you know
I got a small head weight flex it has
two sizes though I know yeah so you
ready get yeah you don't want a small
medium or the large al and I don't know
nothing about this
you're not even about that at all don't
know he returned you back to it hoodies
hats knob over here yeah hoodies
lightweight and do you find use for a
lightweight hoodie definitely all the
time year-round
yes sir I agree not everyone agreed with
that one of theirs yes some wool yes so
the ones we have yes they have a zipper
I'm a fan of I'm a fan of the zipper
zipper light hoodie with the pockets
agree I I honestly I don't even have any
of my own in my apparel line at the
moment but I'm a fan of those yeah -
yeah well Bango is saying you know I
mean I'm mister or heavy hoodie
that's all functional and I get it you
know but a zipped up non or as ipping
lightweight yeah play some warm guard
without for sure and you know hopefully
it looks good hope hopefully you like
the design but you will be representing
while you're on the path a lot of good
stuff on there Jocko store.com some
patches on there too i reorganize I did
I made a mistake
yeah hey I made a mistake I don't want
to go too deep into it but it resulted
in patches not being available for a
little while they're gonna be available
you know you can't buy what's not
available so yeah yeah that's what
they're telling me to and I was like
dang okay alright so you know you learn
something new every day
and you know speaking of which right on
top of things trying to be genitive beep
baby
anyway smash the like button oh my god I
keep saying that to me oh she she
doesn't even know what that mean I think
she halfway knows what that means it's
like smash the like button I was like
Breathitt the video that you're
pretending to make doesn't even have a
like button no no you need to just I got
a no no no I got a stopped her from
saying that that's what I can say but if
you're in the mood to smash if you want
to subscribe to this podcast you
can so do that if you want unaware of
you listen but don't forget about the
warrior kid podcast which there are now
three new or your kid podcasts live at
this time you know good one stories from
Uncle Jake stories that teach lessons an
interview with John Bozak the warrior
kid artist that drew Mike in a dragon is
talking about how to get better at art
how to use art as a tool so when we
inveterate other things yeah it was good
man it was good that those like I do you
do any art I didn't draw in my books no
but I mean yeah I can draw yeah he sent
me a man and I'm gonna post this online
Americans oil paintings Oh Pharrell Ross
have you been into that for like a long
time was that like a new situation I did
my first painting in 2000 a stir of 2016
yeah it's what kind of new oh yes yeah
like oh when I was three I did my no I'm
definitely not jockle has the original
logo where I have the original logo of
Escalon front
Jacques design actually designed some
other stuff too yep that's our
intercourse so he drew it right but so
disconnect was that I drew it I didn't
draw on when I am with my hand I drew it
on the computer like I drew it on
PowerPoint it's so bad boy it's so funny
because when I first go any first send
it to me I'm like yeah of course you
drew it on PowerPoint you know it's not
like you have one of those you adds and
study your chocolate you don't have that
kind stuff so but it's not as obvious
when you get it you just get the
finished product and it literally looks
like my daughter drew it with her left
hand she's right-handed by the way and
but the concept was legitimate it was
sound is what the National Front logo is
at this time so you're pushing and been
received
but the canoeing part of it I tried to
explain it to you you know nine
different times and you kept sending me
back junk yeah well I mean I said okay
pictures worth a thousand words I don't
feel like explaining this a thousand
times if let's just send them a
rudimentary sketch of the concept which
you then chiseled out into right you
know
yeah emphasis on the rudimentary by the
way but the the comedic part of it is
how it looked it looked like a child
drew it so now anytime like if you ask
Amalia have you been into art boom that
flashes in my head and he says yes boom
makes it more funny yeah I'm gonna post
it online so we all can have a good
laugh less yes we're kid bought gasses
out that interview with John bullseye is
very good like especially like cuz it is
he talks about getting like frustrated
with stuff that's little kids yeah it
was good
don't forget about warrior kids soap
from Irish Oaks ranch calm that young
Aiden is making on his farm you get soap
you can stay clean but also we have a
YouTube channel if you're interested in
the video version and see what Mitch
looks like I am I'm handsome you might
be the buffest guess we've ever had
right buffest yes yeah like out of 185
yeah we've only had like probably 10 or
15 you know how many fucking times
people you and Tim Kennedy need to fight
and I'm like okay have you seen can Tim
Kennedy's way bigger than me first of
all fights at 85 I know yeah what do you
fight at 70 yeah 70 I've walked around I
have fought at 185 as well as a champion
at 185 to I walk around close to 200
yeah yeah yeah else no team is like 215
220 he's a big dude I've met just in
passing
I shook his hand one time but yeah he's
a big dude and uh but I was always I
always tell me like that's not way of
like kind of like similar stories like
there's it wouldn't make sense for us
double yeah they just want to see Andy
what a psychological warfare is an album
with tracks wait wait no back to YouTube
we have a youtube channel
I'm gonna demand is part of the value
it's just like a big part is gonna
stretch don't don't undersell that yeah
yeah but you know we
some excerpts on that is what I was
gonna say you know if you don't watch
the whole thread guess there's excerpts
on there anyway some of them are
enhanced by echo yeah some puts his art
work on to the video
it may might be slightly better than my
original a chillon front maybe logo and
maybe a little bit better there's a
murmur over enhanced yes some people
think yeah people think you're under
enhanced yes guard list no less we have
a YouTube channel that's the point
yeah hey if you want to you can smash a
like button share comment subscribe
whatever the three things anyway
psychological warfare is an album with
tracks if you're running into moments of
weakness put in psychological warfare
you'll see it'll solve your problem no
weakness weak just overcome if the if
you want the visual version of that go
to flipside canvas dot-com my brother
Dakota Meyer has a little company where
he's making things that you hang on your
wall artistically some people calm
artistic things again and you can get
those if you want him to make a special
one yeah hit him up on Twitter do some
custom if it's like if it seems to get
some traction yeah he can put it out
yeah he's good he's doing good stuff
yeah on there yeah I check him up from
time to time flip side cameras doc oh
yeah also on it so you got on it calm
slash dropper you get a lot of good
stuff on there including kettle bells
other workout stuff and bring my routine
I'm gonna Hawaii by the way mmm
for one month I know people people
really don't they
under sell Hawaii I feel like I feel
that was the same way when I went there
for the first time I was blown away
where'd you go Maui and Oahu I'm gonna
koi yeah one month I heard that's
beautiful
yes sir it is so I'm bringing the rings
your request by the way that was one of
the selling points of rings is that you
can bring him places too
that wasn't really my request it was a
statement yes statement on a
recommendation recommendation she may be
reluctant recommendation you sure did
they it was a real it was a legitimate
recommendation nonetheless I'm taking it
I'm taking them
you Hawaii anyway point is the Rings I
have it from on and you can get those
who need kettlebells you can get I have
this kid they have this mineral
electrolyte like mix right and I think I
might have just enhanced what I call the
mega mix it's the pre-workout mega
mixers - there's one for jiu-jitsu one
for lifting one for you - is just one
scoop of discipline a little bit of
Gatorade so it's a half gatorade half
water mix optional Gatorade some people
they don't like Gatorade some people
yeah and that's cool
I don't you can put lemon juice in there
if you want sure um like I said they
just win the electrolytes from on it and
then uh I want to add your greens I'll
hook you up yeah that'll be the mega
mega mix that's prejudicial is there a
certain time where you gotta take those
greens no just whenever I get them in
come on all day yeah boom
so that's gonna be the pre jujitsu the
pre lifting is essentially the same
thing except you put or like the
caffeinated pre-workout in it if you're
into it anyway anyway back to on it
that's where you get it there's a lot of
cool stuff on there quite a large a
large human being yourself man looking
good yeah but I don't sound big though
thank you
perspective sorry does my voice not
match how I look you know I can't say
because as you saw me I started talking
maybe not though had you not spoke I'd
been like damn yeah this dude's probably
fucking got a jack voice yeah yeah like
talkin or something yeah but it's
melodious it's not Jack no sir I have it
I have a high-pitched voice
melodious yeah very melodious yes
interesting anyway yeah got some books
where the warrior Kid 3 it's out it's
called where there's a will teaching
kids about how to go harder that's a
little lesson in this book you know you
gotta push harder and also teaching them
about their ego and how their ego will
get them in trouble everyone wishes they
would have learned about ego earlier
because it makes your life better
of course there's way the warrior could
wanna wear the word your kid to March
mission those books are for kids to
learn to get on the path
if they're a little bit younger than
that you can get a Mikey in the Dragons
you know they can learn about how to
overcome their fear there's actual
pragmatic protocols that you can take as
a human being to overcome what you're
afraid of
why not learn that when you're 5 years
old yeah that's my question
why not because you didn't know the but
about the book Mikey in the Dragons now
you know about it your kids are just out
there conquering fears which is a
positive thing mm-hmm yeah and that's a
good one too because you can like you
know if you have a bedtime routine and
you read to your you know four or five
year old before they can mean it's one
where you can read it not only can you
read the whole thing if you want goes
like a 15 minute you know but they'll
want to hear it again so it's like a you
know so one year real while urania over
and over again that lesson will be
instilling green and instilled in burn
deeper rather than just one of the many
books repetition exactly then we got to
displace freedom field manual if you go
hey joko can you post your workouts yes
there in the discipline equals freedom
field manual hey Jacque what do you
think you should do in a situation like
this oh it's in the discipline equals
freedom Field Manual hey jockle we eat
it's in the manual
what's your sleep routine is in the
manual do you take naps it's in the
manual it's all in there
so the discipline equals freedom Field
Manual the guide to getting after it if
you want the audio version of that it's
on iTunes and Amazon music on all the
mp3 things then of course we got extreme
ownership and that I gotta me of
leadership written me by me and my
brother life babban those are gonna help
you become a better leader in your
business with your family and in your
life watch it happen of course we have a
tional on front which is my leadership
consultancy and what we do is solve
problems through leadership because all
the problems that you're having in your
life right now in an organization are
leadership problems I don't care what
they are and if you want to solve those
problems you have to fix your leadership
and that's what we do it's me Lafe Babb
and JP Danelle Dave Burke yes
Flynn Cochran Mike Cirelli Mike bimah
and Jason Garner go to a chillon front
comm for details we also have EF
online which is online leadership
training which is something that's hard
to comprehend how are you gonna take
leadership and teach people leadership
from an online thing an online training
program well you read about it you take
tests on it and then you get put in
scenarios interactive scenarios on the
computer where you have to make
decisions so that's a EF online then we
have the muster which is a leadership
conference the leadership event so
during a gathering that it's all it's
all of the muster is what it is yeah so
it's a muster is but it's the mustard no
muss to you so look the muster
leadership they've all sold out and
they're all gonna sell out the next one
is September 19th and 20th and Denver
after that December 4th and 5th and
Sydney Australia check out extreme
ownership calm for details if you want
to come don't wait to register cuz then
you won't be able to go and you'll be
mad at me and I and you'll send me a
like let's say you're my friend let's
say you're someone I actually know sure
pathetically and and and we're doing
them a muster up in San Francisco and
you send me a text it says hey sorry for
letting you know late you said you're
gonna hook me up with some tickets it's
cool I can make it I'm bringing two
friends and I'm like well first of all
no because it's literally sold out it's
not like hey it's sold out but we can
still let people in that's not sold out
it's sold out yeah so don't wait and
then of course we have the eff overwatch
where we take proven combat leaders from
Special Operations from combat aviation
and put them into companies in the
civilian sector that need leadership
leadership is the most important thing
on the battlefield why not get battle
tested leaders to help out you inside
your business go to EF over watch.com
and if you want to ask me a question us
a question you want to give me an answer
did I mess something up today probably
you want to let me know about that
please
it Mitch as he said he is on Instagram
Mitch underscore a gr a G you I a are an
echo and I are what we're on Twitter and
Instagram and on - facebooking school
echo is that echo Charles and I am at
Jocko willing echo anything else nothing
else thank you thank you guys for having
me very much I really appreciate the
hospitality and opportunity I had a home
awesome
well Mitch thanks for coming on
appreciate it and thanks for working the
teams and I'm sure you're gonna keep
putting forth maximum effort to smash
people in the cage look forward to
seeing that and to all the other vets
out there and to those that are still in
uniform thank you for standing watch
over freedom for our great nation into
our police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and EMTs and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and Border Patrol Secret Service and all
the first responders I travel around the
country and I run into you all the time
and I see what you're doing out there
working and working hard and the reason
that we live safely here in our country
is you so thank you for holding the line
here at home and everyone else out there
remember that you can't hit the pause
button then it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter at all if you get knocked down or
you get tripped up or you think that
something isn't fair it doesn't matter
you still don't get to stop so get back
up bite down on your mouthpiece and go
get after it and until next time this is
Mitch a gr and Necco and Jocko out